CALL THE MEETING OF BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE SIX.
TO.
WE'RE GONNA WAIT TO COLOR TO
ORDER BY THINK WE ARE GOING TO
GET STARTED WITH OUR.
AGENDA.
AND THE WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN
BY.
REVIEWING THE SAFEGUARDING
CALIFORNIA REPORT THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN OPTED TO CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE. ADAPTATION WE HAVE
MISTER BRIGHT FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCE AGENCIES.
MR BRIGHT WELCOME.
WE COPY.
MR.
BUT THEY APPEAR.
OKAY HAVE ALREADY OKAY.
THEY ARE PERFECT.
SO.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
.
I AM VERY EXCITED TO BE HERE
TODAY.
I.
WORKED FOR LONGTIME THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AND I'M.
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO BE BACK
HERE. I'M TALKING TO YOU ABOUT
THIS PLAN THAT I THINK DOES A
LOT OF SIMILARITIES TO THE WORK
THAT YOU DO IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE
PROCESS BUT ALSO.
IN THE BUDGET. AS A WHOLE.
I'M HERE TO TALK TODAY ABOUT.
.
GENERALLY WHAT WE ARE DOING AT
THE STATE TO PROTECT STATE
SERVICES TO.
BUT I.
WHAT WE'RE DOING AT THE STATE
PROTECT STATE SERVICES FROM THE
IMPACT CLIMATE CHANGE BUT MORE
SPECIFICALLY I AM HERE TO
PRESENT ON THE SAFE CUTTING
CALIFORNIA PLAN WHICH REALLY IS
THE BLUEPRINT FOR? HOW OUR
DEPARTMENTS AND OUR AGENCIES
PLAN TO ENSURE THAT SERVICES ARE
DELIVERED TO THE PEOPLE THAT
DEPEND ON THEM IN THE?
?
OVER TIME AS WE SEE THESE
CHANGES OCCUR.
SO.
WHETHER WE.
YOU KNOW.
WHETHER WE TALK ABOUT FIRES
FLOODS DROUGHTS.
OR AND INCREASING HEAT THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE ARE
ARE ACCELERATING THEM ALL AROUND
US RIGHT NOW.
AND.
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU SEE THOSE
IMPACTS FRONT AND CENTER IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO.
CAN OF LOOK JUST BEYOND THOSE
IMPACTS BECAUSE WHILE THOSE.
ARE OFTENTIMES CATASTROPHES AND
HAVE INCREDIBLE SHOCKS ACROSS
THE LANDSCAPE IN OUR IN OUR IN
OUR OUR COMMUNITIES.
BEHIND THOSE THOSE IMPACTS YOU
REALLY HAVE.
.
YOU REALLY HAVE A.
THE MULTIPLICATION OF THOSE
SHOCKS THROUGHOUT. ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT.
COMMUNITIES AND SERVICES THAT
THOSE COMMUNITIES DEPEND ON
ACROSS THE STATE.
IN MANY WAYS THE WAY THOSE
THOSE THOSE EVENTS MULTIPLY
ACROSS LANDSCAPE ALSO CONSTRAINS
HOW THEM STATE GOVERNMENTS ABLE
TO PROVIDE.
SERVICES TO TO PEOPLE AND TO.
CENTER TIPTON NATURAL SYSTEMS
AND.
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE IS IS PUT TOGETHER A
BLUEPRINT SO THAT OUR STATE
AGENCIES CAN. CAN CAN BREAK THIS
DOWN INTO SMALLER BITES AND AND
KIND OF GET AWAY FROM WHAT IS
OFTEN REALLY PARALYZING AND
DAUNTING WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
WHAT WE FACE.
SO IS THAT IS IS AN EXAMPLE OF
THIS AND GET TO THE REPORT A
MINUTE BUT IN IT WHEN WE HAD OUR
WHEN WE HAD A RECENT.
CAN A SOMEWHAT RECENT DROUGHT.
YOU KNOW WE HAD UP IN THE FRONT
WE HAD WE HAD AGRICULTURAL AND.
AND MUNICIPAL WATER SUPPLY.
ISSUES STARING AT US DALY BUT
THEN. BEHIND THOSE ISSUES WE
REALLY SAW THESE
THESE WE SAW THOSE IMPACTS KIND
OF SPREAD ACROSS
SOCIAL SYSTEMS AND POLICY AREAS
THAT YOU GUYS FOCUS ON IT
SUBCOMMITTEES.
AND WE HAD INCREASED NEEDS FOR
FOOD ASSISTANCE THEM ACROSS THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BECAUSE THERE WAS
SPIKING AND EMPLOYMENT FROM LACK
OF AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTION.
WE HAD.
WE HAD YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF A
LACK OF SNOWPACK AND AND AND A
LOT AND AND INCREASED HEAT WHICH
WHICH MULTIPLY THE DROUGHTS
IMPACTS. WE HAD.
.
UNPRECEDENTED STRESS ON OUR
STATES FOREST IN IN IN A WE SEE
THE FIRES THAT THAT THAT THAT.
THE THAT THAT SITUATION LENDS TO
BUT WHAT WE DON'T SEE IS THAT.
THE REGION'S THE RURAL REGIONS.
ARE ALSO START FROM TOURISM AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT WHEN THEY
WHEN THEY EXPERIENCE IMPACTS
THAT.
ARE INITIALLY CAUSED BY THESE
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS.
SO THE SAFEGUARDING CALIFORNIA
PLAN.
IS REALLY INTENDED TO.
TO. LOOK ACROSS STATE GOVERNMENT
ANTICIPATE THE IMPACTS THAT
WERE.
EXPERIENCING BASING ON. YOU KNOW
THAT THE MOST UP TO DATE SCIENCE
AND INFORMATION THAT'S COMING
OUR WAY.
BUT THEN.
.
DIGGIN AND ACTUALLY SERVE A OUR
PROGRAMS ARE PROGRAM MANAGERS
ARE STATE AGENCIES FOR WHAT THEY
ARE DOING TO TO TO TO.
.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING CURRENTLY?
TO RESPOND OF THESE IMPACTS.
BUT ALSO WHETHER THAN ONE OF THE
THE THE REALISTIC BUT AMBITIOUS
NEXT STEPS THEY SHOULD BE
ENGAGING IN.
WHAT WE WANNA DO IS PRESENT AN
ARC OF WORK THAT THAT IS
ACHIEVABLE FOR THESE AGENCIES SO
WERE WERE WERE SETTING A BAR?
THAT CAN JUST CONSISTENTLY PUSH
OUR PROGRAMS TO PLACES WHERE
THEY ARE. THEY ARE THEY ARE
BEING MORE RESPONSIVE IN BEING
MORE AMBITIOUS BUT THEY'RE ALSO.
BEING REALISTIC ABOUT WHAT IS
WHAT IS POSSIBLE AS THEY FACE
THESE ISSUES.
THE SCOPE OF THE PLAN IS IS IS
VERY.
DELIBERATELY CONSTRAINED AROUND
STATE GOVERNMENT.
WE WANTED THE PLAN TO SERVE AS
A.
.
CLEAN TOOL FOR STATE POLICY
MAKERS LIKE YOURSELVES.
.
TO LOOK AT TO LOOK AT OUR STATE
PROGRAMS AND LOOK AT THE IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND REALLY BE
ABLE TO ASSESS.
IF OUR RESPONSES ADEQUATE IF WE
NEED TO PUSH HARDER OR IF WE
NEED TO YOU KNOW IF THERE ARE IF
THERE ARE SOME BLIND SPOTS THAT
WERE WERE MISSING IN OUR IN OUR
RESPONSE.
IT ALSO.
PUSHES OUR STATE AGENCIES TO TO
INCORPORATE CUTTING EDGE SCIENCE
THAT THE STATE.
.
PRIMARILY THE STATE BUT OTHER
PARTNERS ARE INVESTING IN RIGHT
NOW THAT WILL BE COMING OUT
LATER THIS YEAR THAT WILL THERE
BUT THAT THAT THE PROVIDES DOWN
TO THE NEIGHBORHOOD TYPE DATA.
ON WHAT THE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
ARE SO THE TEMPERATURE INCREASES
THAT WERE SHOULD WE WE EXPECTED
IN ON A COASTAL COMMUNITY VERSES
THE TEMPERATURE INCHED INCREASES
THAT WILL EXPERIENCE. UP IN THE
M. UP IN THE UP IN THE FOOTHILLS
UP TO THE MOUNTAINS.
AND AND THAT THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE ALLOWS THOSE
WHERE WE HAVE STATE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE SPREAD ACROSS THE
ENTIRE STATE. IT ALLOWS THEM TO
MODIFY THEIR PROGRAMS IN A WAY
THAT THAT REALLY IS RESPONSIVE
TO THE CONDITIONS AT HAND AND
THE CONDITIONS THAT THEY EXPECT
TO TO SEE IN THE FUTURE.
.
WE ARE ALSO BUILDING BEHIND THAT
SCIENCE WE'RE BUILDING. TOOLS
ANALYTICAL TOOLS TO ALLOW THESE
POP POLICYMAKERS TO SEE VISUALLY
AND SPATIALLY HOW THOSE IMPACTS
WILL BE IMPACTING THEM AND THOSE
TOOLS ARE ALSO AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS
WELL.
SO.
I THINK THE STORY OF HOW HOW THE
SAFEGUARDING PLAN WAS DEVELOPED
IS ALMOST AS IMPORTANT AS THE
CONTENT OF THE PLAN.
THE PLAN ITSELF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCIES IS DIRECTED
BY STATUTE TO ORGANIZE
PRODUCTION OF THIS PLAN BUT IT
REALLY IS. IT REALLY IS A A
STATEWIDE DOCUMENT THAT YOU KNOW
WE HAVE WE HAVE CONTROL OVER OUR
CHANNEL BUT WE DON'T. QUITE HAVE
AUTHORITY TO TO TO DICTATE HOW
OTHER AGENCIES DO THEIR BUSINESS
SO WE ENGAGED IN AN IN AN
UNPRECEDENTED.
COLLABORATE COLLABORATED
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT ACROSS
STATE GOVERNMENT ALMOST OVER
THIRTY DIFFERENT STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES.
GUM CONTRIBUTING TO THIS BOOK.
AND WORK AND I AM.
I THINK THE SOCIALIZING ASPECT
IS FOR ME IS ONE OF THE
STRONGEST TAKEAWAYS IS THAT YOU
KNOW FROM MY OWN EXPERIENCE I'VE
REALLY SEEN A SHIFT WHERE. IN
THE PAST THAT THE CLIMATE THE
CLIMATE PLANNING ELEMENTS OF OUR
STATE AGENCIES AND STATE
DEPARTMENTS. AND A LOT OF WAYS
IS REALLY SILENT OFF FROM THAT
FROM THE DAY TO DAY BUSINESS
THAT ARE THAT ARE DEPARTMENTS GO
THEN ENGAGE IN.
AND AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW
ARE THESE THIS KIND OF THIS
TIGHTER INTEGRATION BETWEEN THE
CLIMATE PROGRAMS AND IN IN THE
THE EVERYDAY PROGRAMS ACROSS ALL
OVER AGENCIES.
.
WE STRUCTURE THIS PLAN MUCH LIKE
A BUDGET IS STRUCTURED WE WE
ORGANIZED AROUND.
STE ELEVEN KEY POLICY AREAS SO
THING OF A FEW MORE THAN THE SUB
COMMITTEES BUT WE WE BATCH THEM
IN MANY WAYS LIKE THEIR PASSED
IN SUBCOMMITTEE.
WE ORGANIZED AROUND PROGRAM
ACTIVITIES RATHER THAN POLICIES
SO SO IT YOU KNOW YOU WHEN YOU
READ TO THE PLAN YOU'LL SEE
THINGS LOOK A LOT LIKE. BCP'S
AND AND AND NEXT YOU KNOW AND AN
EXPENDITURE REPORTS.
.
WE.
IN EACH POLICY AREA WE WE WE WE
STARTED WITH COME HIGH LEVEL
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEMES IN
THAT WE BUILT. WE BUILT OUT
RECOMMENDATIONS UNDERNEATH THAT
FOR THE PROGRAMS.
AND.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT REALLY IS
INTENDED TO DOIS TO GIVE GIVE
THOSE INTERESTED IN DIFFERENT
POLICY AREAS.
.
JUST A WAY TO TO WHEN THEY ASK
WHEN THE YOU KNOW WHEN THEY HAVE
THE TIME TO ASK THE QUESTION ARE
WE PREPARED TO RESPOND CLIMATE
CHANGE. IN THIS SPECIFIC POLICY
AREA IT REALLY GIVES THAT PERSON
BLUEPRINT START ASKING QUESTIONS
OF DRILLING DOWN AND PUSHING ON
THE AGENCIES AND AND AND HOLDING
HOLDING FOLKS ACCOUNTABLE.
I HAVE A FEW EXAMPLES I WANTED
TO TALK YOU THROUGH IN THE PLANT
SO IT'S NOT JUST ME TALKING BUT.
I THINK THE FIRST ONE I WANTED
TO TURN TO IS ON PAGE.
I'M JUST TO SHOW YOU HOW THE
THAT THE PLAN IS STRUCTURED.
.
AND GIVE YOU A SENSE OF HOW THEY
CONNECT ACROSS POTS HERE IS THE
FIRST ONE WAS IN THE M.
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT SECTION OF
PAGE SIX
TWO. AND IT WOULD BE TITLED IN
THIS IS VERY WANT KIDS FEDERAL
E. M. DASH THREE POINT ONE D..
AND AND AND THERE'S THERE'S A
METHOD TO THAT LABELING BUT I'M
IN THE.
THE FIRST THING IT SAYS
INCORPORATE CLIMATE
CONSIDERATION DROUGHT AND
EMERGENCY PLANNING
IT'S A VERY GENERAL
RECOMMENDATION THE NET THEN
YOU'LL SEE THE WATER MARK NEXT
TO IT. IN THE WATER SECTION OF
THE PLANE YOU'LL SEE FOLLOW
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT MATCH THAT.
IN AN THOSE TOGETHER YOU KNOW
THE WORK THAT'S BEING ON THE
GROUND HAS EMERGED. THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES WORK IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES AND REALLY BUILDING UP
LOCAL PLANS TO RESPOND TO THE.
TO THE FLOOD RISKS THAT WE SEE
NOT ONLY IN OUR MAJOR RIVER WAYS
BUT ALSO IN THE URBAN WATER
SYSTEMS THAT ARE ARE MANY TIMES
MUCH MORE UNPREDICTABLE.
THE NEXT THE NEXT ONE HOPEFULLY
AND. I HAVE SOME TIME PUBLIC
HEALTH ON PAGE ONE OF FIVE.
THE HIGH LEVEL THE HIGH LEVEL
GOAL HERE IS TO ESTABLISH AN
IMPROVE AND MAINTAIN ROBUST
SURVEILLANCE MECHANISMS.
SO ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
IS REALLY.
IS MAKING SURE YOU HAVE EYES ON
THE POPULATION TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THESE CHANGES ARE IMPACTING OUR
ARE THE PEOPLE AND THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THAT. YOU KNOW.
THEY'RE ALL AROUND US AND. YOU
KNOW THOSE THOSE SIGNALS ARE NOT
ALWAYS OBVIOUS SO. IN HERE WE
IDENTIFY SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS TO TO TO TO GIVE
THE DEPARTMENT A PUBLIC HEALTH
THE ABILITY TO TRACK THESE
IMPACT IS THAT GOING TO THE
CONCERT MONITORING THEM.
AND THEN THE LAST.
I HAVE ONE MORE
TRANSPORTATION BUT I THINK MIGHT
HAVING SYSTEMS.
LOG OF THE LAST ONE BECAUSE I.
IN OCEANS IN CO STEM PAGE ONE
SEVENTY TWO. THERE'S A WHOLE
SUITE OF RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND.
PLANNING AN ADAPTATION TO
REDUCE HAZARDS TO INCREASE
RESILIENCE OF COASTAL
COMMUNITIES INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT AND OTHER RESOURCES.
WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME ARM.
NOT ONLY IS THIS.
NEAR THE ISSUES OF SEA LEVEL
RISING COASTAL.
.
COSTA RESILIENCY COULD I SPREAD
THROUGHOUT THE DOCUMENT BUT WHEN
YOU START TO LOOK AT THE ICONS
NEXT TO THESE RECOMMENDATIONS.
YOU REALLY SEE HOW THOSE LINK TO
POLICY AREAS THAT. YOU KNOW SEA
LEVEL RISE IS OFTEN TALKED ABOUT
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE BUT SEA LEVEL
RISE REALLY SHOULD BE TALKED
ABOUT IN EVERY SUBCOMMITTEE AS
IT AS IT IMPACTS THOSE. POLICY
AREAS AND WHAT WE TRY TO DO AND
IT'S BETTER ONLINE WE YOU KNOW
WE WE TRIED IT WE LINK THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS SO THE PUBLIC
CAN. CONTRACT THAT AS A BECAUSE
AROUND.
.
SO THE LAST THING I WANTED TO
POINT OUT WAS WE. WE DID ALL WE
PUT A LOT OF THEM WORK AND
REALLY REALLY IN IT WITH SUPPORT
FROM OUR OUR. OUR PHILANTHROPIC
PARTNERS ON THIS REPORT.
INTO.
ENSURING THAT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE HAVE
ACROSS EVERY POLICY AREA.
YOU KNOW REALLY GET AT THE
QUESTIONS OF EQUITY.
A CLIMATE JUSTICE.
AND.
.
YOU KNOW THOSE THAT THOSE THAT
ARE.
CLEMENT JUSTICE TO ME YOU KNOW
THE RELIGIOUS MEANS OF THAT THAT
HIGH IN OF THOSE THAT HAVE THE
HARDEST GO IN LIFE.
REALLY ARE GONNA THE HARD AGO
WHEN WHEN CLIMATE IMPACTS COME
INTO THOSE COMMUNITIES HOW DO
YOU. HOW DO YOU BUILD UP TO
SUPPORT SYSTEMS TO? TO MAKE SURE
THAT THUMBED THEIR NEEDS ARE
ADDRESSED BUT ALSO THAT THERE
THEIR VOICES ARE CAPTURED IN THE
PLANNING PROCESS ARE GOING TO
HAPPEN.
ACROSS THESE DIFFERENT POLICY
AREAS OVER TIME.
.
WE HAD. SO ONE PAGE THIRTY ONE.
THE CLIMATE THIRTY PITCH THIRTY
THIRTY ONE THE CLIMATE JUSTICE
CHAPTER I'M IS THE PRODUCT OF
EXTENSIVE COLLABORATION WITH
THE.
.
WITH THE
CLIMATE JUSTICE WORKING GROUP
HAS HAVE A LOT OF WORKING
GROUP'S MAP BUT THE THE CLIMATE
JUSTICE WORKING GROUP WHICH HAD.
WHICH HAD PARTICIPANTS FROM
FROM NGOS CROSS THE STATE IN
THOSE PARTICIPANTS WERE GIVEN
SCHOLARSHIPS BY THE BY THE
FOUNDATION COMMUNITY TO
PARTICIPATE.
THEY PROVIDED.
INCREDIBLE.
INPUT TO OUR INITIAL DRAFT AND
WE REALLY WORKED WITH THEM TO T
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE SPREAD
ACROSS.
.
SO KIND OF WHAT COMES NEXT WITH
THIS WE HAVE WE HAVE OVER A
THOUSAND RECOMMENDATIONS WE HAVE
WE HAVE WE WHERE WE'VE WE'VE.
HUNDREDS OF AND ALMOST A
THOUSAND OF ONGOING ACTIONS
YOU KNOW WHAT COMES NEXT SO
THERE. THERE'S GOING TO BE AN
EFFORT THIS YEAR AND THIS ISN'T
STATURE TO.
TRACK
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF ALL OF
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS AND I
THINK THE CLOSEST THAT I CAN A
LINE THAT TO RIGHT NOW IS IS THE
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT ON THE
THAT THAT THE ABILITY OF
DEPARTMENTS TO MEET. AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS SO WORRYING WORK
WE'RE GOING DEEP INTO THAT THAT
EXTREME DATA DIVE RIGHT NOW IF A
FIGURE OUT HOW TO TRACK.
EACH OF THESE AGENCIES AND HAVE
THEM TRUCK THEMSELVES AS PART OF
THAT SOCIALIZING THAT BUT TOOL
TO GET THEM FOCUSED ON THESE
ISSUES.
I THINK WE'RE REALLY IN THE
LEARNING PHASE RIGHT NOW OF HOW
TO HOW TO TRACK PROGRESS SO. YOU
KNOW THAT'LL BE THIS YEAR IN THE
FUTURE WE MAY ONE AROUND THAT UP
INTO SOMETHING MORE. MORE.
GENERAL AND PROGRAMMATIC
INFEASIBLE BUT. WE'RE NOT QUITE
THERE YET.
.
AND THEN LAST YOU KNOW.
ULTIMATELY.
I THINK WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT
ABOUT THIS PLAN IS THE QUESTION
OF HOW SHOULD IT BE USED.
.
ALL WE DESIGNED THIS DOCUMENT SO
THAT IT IT. IT REALLY IS MEANT
TO BE TRANSPARENT ACCOUNTABILITY
TOOL ACROSS GOVERNMENT.
.
AND IT SHOULD ANSWER THE
QUESTION FOR EVERYONE AND
WHATEVER DAY TO DAY BUSINESS
THAT THEY WORK ON IN THIS
BUILDING AND AN ACROSS THE STATE
ARE WE READY FOR CLIMATE CHANGE
THAT THAT ISN'T JUST AN
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE IT'S
SOMETHING THAT MULTIPLIES CROSS
TRANSPORTATION HEALTH.
PARKS AND RECREATION CULTURE
YOU KNOW EVERYWHERE YOU LOOK.
AND THE LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW MY
HOPE IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN
REALLY USE THIS AS A AS A
CLIMATE LOANS AND WITH WITH WITH
YOU ALL WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
BUDGETS.
AS A POLICY LENDS WHEN WE WHEN
WE WHEN WE DRAFT BILLS WE LOOK
AT PROPOSED PROGRAMS.
BUT ALSO IN OF THE PUBLIC SHOULD
BE ABLE TO USE THIS AS A AS A
TOOL TO REALLY PUSH ON STATE
GOVERNMENT.
WHEN THEY SEE AREAS THAT WERE
WERE QUITE FRANKLY LACKING HONOR
THEY YOU KNOW. WHERE THEY SEE
IMPROVEMENT IS NEEDED?
AND THEN LAST IN IN THIS IS
REALLY THIS IS REALLY.
TAKING OFF
IN A WE'RE IN THIS WERE IN THE
STATE WIDE COLLECTIVE EFFORT
RIGHT NOW TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
THIS IS NOT THIS IS A DYNAMIC
CHANGING NEW.
AREA PLANNING WERE WERE CHASING
IN A TREND LINES THAT ARE THAT
ARE NOT COMPLETELY STABLE HONOR
THEIR GOING UP AND DOWN.
.
WE HOPE THAT THIS PLAN REALLY
SERVES AS THE FIRST OF ITS KIND
IN CALIFORNIA ANOTHER STATES WE
HOPE THAT. THAT OTHER
JURISDICTIONS AMUSES AS A MODEL
FOR THEIR OWN PLANNING EFFORTS.
BUT THEN YOU KNOW.
THE ONLY WAY THAT'S REALLY WORKS
AS A PHASES OF THE MODEL LEARN
FROM US AND THEN DO A BETTER
THEMSELVES. AND WE CAN COME BACK
IN THREE YEARS WE'RE STATUTORILY
REQUIRED TO IMPROVE THIS AND
LEARN OFF AT THEIR WORK SO WE
HAVE VERY STRONG COLLABORATIVE'S
WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AROUND. ON THIS PLAN AND WHAT
THEY'RE DOING IN AND THE WAY
THAT. WE'RE WE'RE SETTING UP OUR
SYSTEMS AS WELL HAVE THAT WILL
HAVE THAT THAT FEEDBACK LOOP SO
THAT THE NEXT TIME WE COME.
TO DRAFT THIS DOCUMENT WE WILL
HAVE LEARNED QUITE A BIT.
SO.
THE LAST THING I WANTED TO
MENTION IS THAT THIS PLAN. YOU
KNOW FOCUSES JUST ON WHAT STATE
GOVERNMENT IS DOING. THEM.
IT IS IN A STATEMENT OF WHERE WE
ARE IN CLIMATE CHANGE WHAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING. THIS SUMMER AND
FALL THE STATE WILL BE RELEASING
OVER FIFTY STUDIES THAT ARE
GONNA BE DONE BY INSTINCT EIGHT
RESEARCH INSTITUTIONS FROM THE
UC SYSTEM THE STATE SYSTEM TO
STANFORD PRIVATE.
.
WE ARE GOING TO CONSOLIDATE THAT
INFORMATION AND REALLY PROVIDE A
FINDS GRAIN SCALE.
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT.
STATES.
CLIMATE IMPACTS ARE AND WHAT WE
EXPECT TO SEE IN THE IN THE IN
THE NEAR FUTURE SO. THAT PARTNER
WITH THESE PLANNING TOOLS REALLY
SAID.
SENATE SENATE IN IT AND
HOPEFULLY IN A GOOD DIRECTION.
FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS IN THAT
WE WILL JUST NEED TO REVISIT
THEM SO.
WITH THAT ALL AND COME OPEN FOR
QUESTIONS. GREAT THANK YOU
BEFORE WE BEGIN LET THE TAPE
ROLL TANG HERE ALLEN ARAMBULA
HERE BLOOM.
COOPER THEIR MCCARTY OBERNOLTE
HERE PATTERSON WEBER.
THANK YOU THOUGHT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
MISTER BRECHT.
MR WOULD NOT.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I.
WAS READING IN THE WATER SECTION
OF THE REPORT.
AND. ONE OF THE THINGS CONCERNS
THAT I HAVE IS. THAT.
PROPOSITION ONE ALLOCATED A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF MONEY TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF DIFFERENT
LARGE WATER STORAGE PROJECTS AND
OTHER SECTION.
WAS READING IN THE NEXT STEPS
ABOUT.
DEVELOPING SUBSTANTIVE WATER
STORAGE CONTINGENCY PLANS AND I
WONDERED WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S APPROACH TO
THAT WAS GOING TO BE AND WHETHER
NOT INCLUDED. ABOVE GROUND WATER
STORAGE PROJECTS.
SO SO THE WATER STORAGE.
RECOMMENDATIONS REALLY ARE OUR
FOCUS IT STATEWIDE IN THEY THEY
ABSOLUTELY NAM.
INCLUDE.
ABOVE GROUND STORAGE AND THEN
YOU KNOW CONDUCTIVE BELOW GROUND
STORAGE WHERE THOSE SYSTEMS
MAKES SENSE.
THIS DOCUMENT DOESN'T GET INTO
THE POLICIES OF HOW THOSE TO
HAVE YOU KNOW. THAT LEADS TO THE
WATER OF THAT THE PROCESS IS IN
PLACE TO MAKE DECISIONS ON
STORAGE BUT IT'S A IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FLAG. THE
IMPORTANCE OF OF HAVING THOSE
INSURANCE MECHANISMS IN THE
WATER SUPPLIES YOU GIVE MAXIMIZE
OUR WATER MANAGEMENT OPTIONS.
SO YES IT DOES AND.
AND THEN THAT AS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH THOSE AGENCIES ON
DEVELOPING A.
ALRIGHT PANDA ANOTHER QUESTION
THAT I HAD WAS ARE A REPRESENT A
VERY RURAL AREA OF THE STATE AND
WE HAVE A LOT OF FOR INSTANCE
MARTIN LUTHER SHARE YOUR
CONCERNS ABOUT. FOR STANDING
AND.
THE REDUCTION OF THE POTENTIAL
FOR CATASTROPHIC FIRE.
A BECAUSE THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
ARE BAD FOR THE CLIMATE AND BAD
FOR CALIFORNIA.
BUT I'M CONCERNED WHEN I READ
THE FOREST THINNING SECTION IT
SAID THAT WE HAVE TO PURSUE SOME
THINNING BUT IT DIDN'T REALLY
ADDRESS THE STATE'S.
LACK OF CAPACITY FOR PROCESSING
THOSE THINNING PRODUCTS IN A WAY
THAT'S ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY.
AND I WONDERED IF YOU HAD A PLAN
FOR HOW TO INCREASE THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO DO THOSE.
FACT WE DO HAVE A PLAN I'M IN
ITS IN ITS SHOULD BE RELEASED
SHORTLY BUT WHERE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING.
.
WITH.
ACROSS
MANY AGENCIES STATE AND FEDERAL
AND DO SOME PUBLIC ON THE FORCE
CARBON PLAN.
SPACE DEDICATED TO TO WHAT DO
YOU DO WITH THE MATERIAL.
.
YOU KNOW FOR BOTH OF THE BIOMASS
SIDE BUT ALSO ON THE WOOD
PRODUCTS SIDE WE ALSO WERE
DIRECTED BY S. B. EIGHT FIFTY
NINE IN THE TRAILER BILL TO.
PUT TOGETHER THE WOOD PRODUCTS
WORKING GROUP WHICH WHICH
DELIVERED RECOMMENDATIONS AT THE
BEGINNING THE AIR AND THAT. THAT
WORKING GROUP WAS REALLY
TARGETED THAT.
.
THE NON ENERGY SIDE OF THE OF
THE MATERIAL QUESTIONS HOW DO
YOU HAVE DO YOU STIMULATE
MARKETS FOR THE USE OF THIS
MATERIAL WHEN YOU ENGAGE IN THAT
THAT RAMP UP OF THINNING BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW. THAT THE MATERIALS
THAT ARE THAT ARE CLEARED IN THE
THINNING PROJECT ARE URNT IN
OPEN PILES.
ENOUGH FOR THE MOST PART IN THE
FIELD SO HOW DO WE HAD WE HAD TO
USE THE THROUGH MASS TIMBER YOU
KNOW STE DIFFERENT TYPES OF WOOD
PRODUCTS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE IN.
THERE MANY BENEFITS THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT MARKET WALK
LOOK PAULA FORD READING ABOUT
THAT AND I CAN GET HER TO THE
TOP YOU HAVE BOTH SO FAR. IT IS
IN PARTICULAR I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT LEAKAGE BECAUSE WHEN WE
TAKE THAT THOSE WOOD PRODUCTS
AND WE TO SHIP THEM OFF TO CHINA
OR WHEREVER THEY GO. AYE IF IF
THOSE PRODUCTS ARE USED AND
MARVELING UNFRIENDLY WAY IN
OTHER PLACES IT REALLY DOESN'T
DO LOSS IS A GLOBAL CLIMATE ANY
GOOD AT ALL NEW. ART THANK YOU
VERY.
JUST SORT ECHO MY.
VICE CHAIR SEGMENTS OBVIOUSLY
THIS HAS BEEN OUR.
MAJOR ISSUE ESPECIALLY THIS FALL
AND I KNOW THAT WE HAVE FOUND.
INVESTED SIGNIFICANT DOLLARS
INTO A FOUR STRING THE CAP AND
TRADE BUDGET BUT ALSO TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO.
I THINK WHAT SORT OF HAMPERED
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT WAS WHAT
TO DO WITH THE TREES EVEN AFTER.
WE CAN DO ANYTHING OR ANY
CUTTINGS OUT OF MISTER BLOOM
WHEN YOU ARE JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE SPENDING
SIGNIFICANT TIME ON THE ISLAND.
SUBCOMMITTEE THREE THIS YEAR.
MR CLINTON AREA YOUR YOUR ME
MISTER BLISS VERY GOOD FRIENDS.
THAT'S ALL I HEARD.
ARMED.
BUT KNOW THAT BUT THANK YOU I I
KNOW I AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE ARE WE TOUGH WE WANT TO.
HARM.
FIND A PATH TOGETHER OUGHT TO
WORK TO WORK TOGETHER ON. OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
MISTER CHAIRPERSON HOW DOES IT
ECHO MISTER OBERNOLTE COMMENTS
ON THE WATER STORAGE OBVIOUS
THAT REPRESENT PART OF DELTA.
AND.
THE PUB ONE BEING FUNDS ARE ARE
BOTH PUT PATH BEFORE I CAME
HERE.
SO IN THE STILL NOT BEING BUILT
IN TALKING TO MEMBERS I TALKED
AGENCY.
.
IT'S STILL A PRIORITY SO HERE WE
ARE AND WILL BE GONE BUT TIME
EVEN GET STARTED. SO THAT THAT'S
THE BIG CONCERN AND IT'S NEWER
AND GENDER DROUGHT THIS YEAR THE
WAY IT LOOKS IF WAY THINGS ARE
GOING RIGHT NOW. SO.
AT SOME POINT WE NEED TO.
IS GONNA HAPPEN AS A PRIORITY OR
IS NOT LETTING THE VOTERS SPOKE
WHEN THEY PASSED THE BOND.
AND IT'S TIME TO GET GOING SO
THAT'S THAT THAT THAT'S A
CONCERN I HAVE IS DO A LOT OF
MEMBERS THAT REPRESENT.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
I THINK.
THANK YOU MUST COOPER.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OVERVIEW AND FOR THE
REPORT I'M SURE WILL BE COMING
BACK TO YOU AS WE HAVE A.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND IN THE
BACK AND OBVIOUSLY ARE GOING TO
A WEBSITE AS WELL BUT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT ITEM IS A UPDATE ON
THIS MISSION BASED BUDGETING WE
HAVE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THIS BILL DOES YES HELLO FREE TO
BEGIN.
RG BASIS WITHOUT THE RESEARCH
ANALYSIS UNIT.
AT THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
MYSELF ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUE
JC THOMPSON WHO COULDN'T BE HERE
TODAY.
ARE LEADING THE MISSION BASED
REVIEWS.
OF A NUMBER OF.
DEPARTMENTS.
YOU HAVE TWO HANDOUTS.
THEY'RE GOING AROUND ONE IS
SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU'VE SEEN
BEFORE IT JUST SHOWS A LIST OF
THE. CURRENT PROJECTS AND THEN
THE ONES WE HAVE SLATED.
TO START.
IN THAT IT'S RIP UP COMING UP
BUDGET CYCLES.
AND THEN THE SECOND DOCUMENT IS
SOMETHING NEW IS.
LIST OF OUR CURRENT PROJECTS
AND SORT OF GIVING YOU A STATUS
UPDATE. ON WHERE WERE OUT WITH
THOSE INSERTED SOME OF THE MAJOR
ISSUES WE'VE IDENTIFIED IN AND
NOW I'M OUT ANNA. COMPLETION
DATE THAT WERE HOPING TO HIT.
.
SO SINCE WE MET LAST AND WE'VE
MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS ON THOSE
FIRST FOR.
THAT WE HAVE. AND UNDER WAY
RIGHT NOW REAL ESTATE SERVICES
DIVISION STATE HOSPITALS STATE
FIRE MARSHAL.
AND DEPARTMENT REHABILITATION.
WHAT WE'RE FINDING IS THAT ON
TWO BIG RESEARCH SORT OF ON
STAGES THE FIRST ONE IS JUST
REALLY GETTING IN THERE AND
REALLY UNDERSTANDING.
VERY SORT OF.
THOROUGHLY WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
DOES WHAT THE RESPONSIBILITIES
ARE WHAT THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO.
ON THAT SORT OF HOW THEY GO
ABOUT DOING IT.
SOME HAVE SORT OF MADE STRIDES
IN MODERNIZING THE WAY THEY FEEL
THEIR REQUIREMENTS OTHERS
HAVEN'T.
AND THEN JUST SORT OF REALLY
UNDERSTANDING SORT OF FROM THE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND PEOPLE
RUNNING THESE DEPARTMENTS WHAT.
WHAT THEY'RE CHALLENGES ARE WITH
THEIR STRUGGLES ARE AND SORT OF
A THAT TAKES A REALLY LONG TIME
ESPECIALLY WITH THE REALLY BIG
AND I'M COMPLEX APARTMENT COME
SUCH AS THE DEPARTMENT STATE
HOSPITALS?
ON THE NEXT.
SERVE AS AFTER WE'VE SORT OF
COMPLETE ABOUT FACE BECOME UP A
LIST OF ISSUES THAT WE WANT TO
TACKLING WANNA FIND ANSWERS TO
AND WE WANNA RESULT BASICALLY
PROBLEMS THAT WE WANT TO SOLVE.
ON THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT
NOW WITH THOSE FIRST FLOORS WERE
BASICALLYHAVE THIS LIST OF OF
ISSUES AND PROBLEMS WE WANT TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IN.
AND.
OR DEVELOPING CERTIFIABLY
SOLUTIONS FOR THOSE ANNOUNCED.
LOOKING WHAT WHETHER STATES ARE
DOING LUTE TALKING TO
STAKEHOLDERS SOUND TAKING A DEEP
DIVE INTO THE DATA. SET TO
CONFIGURE WHAT THAT RIGHT ON
FIXES FOR THESE.
I'M WE ALSO PICKED UP TO
ADDITIONAL ON REVIEW SINCE WE
MET LAST ON TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION. AN ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE CONTROL OUR SOULS
FRIEDMAN NESTLE INITIAL RESEARCH
ON PHASES ON THOSE TWO.
.
SO WITH THAT I'M SEVENTIES AND
IN TERMS OF SORT OF TARGET
COMPLETION.
ON SOME OF THESE BIGGER ONES
LIKE STATE HOSPITALS YOU'RE
REALLY GOING TO SORT OF SEE
TANGIBLE PRODUCTS IN KIND OF A
FLOW BASIS RIGHT THIS THIS SPELL
WE WORKED REALLY CLOSELY. WITH
OUR BUDGET COUNTERPARTS TO
REALLY IMPROVE THE TRANSPARENCY
OF ON THE BUDGET STRUCTURE FOR
STATE HOSPITALS THE BUDGET
ESTIMATE BINDER. AND THEN ALSO
ON THE SALARIES AND WAGES
GALLEON WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY INTO THAT
DEPARTMENTS BUDGETS I KNOW
THAT'S BEEN A STRUGGLE FOR. FOR
ELLIE O. COUNTERPARTS.
BUT WE'RE ALSO GOING TO TACKLE
SOME SOME BIG THINGS THEY WORK
ON SOME STOPPING STUDIES IN THE
PAST FEW YEARS ARE GOING TO BE
TACKLING THOSE IN THE NEXT.
FEW MONTHS SO SO THAT'S REALLY
GONNA ONE IT'S GOING TO GO ON
FOR AWHILE AND WE'RE GONNA SORT
OF HAVE TANGIBLE TO LIBERAL
DELIVERABLES THAT'S WE GO.
OVER ALL I CAN SAY THAT WE'VE
HAD REALLY GREAT CLARA
COLLABORATIVE WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR IT
DEPARTMENT COUNTERPARTS.
AND I THINK THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
AND SORT OF WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
FOR THE DEPARTMENTS ARE GONNA
CONTINUE TO SORT OF SERVE
FINANCE AND SERVE THE STATE. FOR
MANY YEARS TO COME.
AND I THINK THAT'S SO THAT'S IT
AND IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ON.
THE ANSWER THEM.
MR OVERLOADED.
SO FAR NO SURPRISE I'M A BIG.
BELIEVER IN THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
DOING.
AND.
OF IT'S REALLY GRATIFYING TO
SEE THE WORK PROGRESS. SO WHO I
JUST WANTED ASSN THIRTY THOUSAND
FOOT VIEW SLASH HAND SO I MEAN
FIRST OF ALL IN THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE. IN THE YEAR SINCE
WE LAST HAD AN UPDATE. OF WHAT
PART OF YOUR WORK PRODUCTS DO
YOU THINK WE CAN INCORPORATE
INTO THE CURRENT BUDGET THAT WE
ARE CONSIDERING.
AND SO WE HAVE DONE.
.
WORK WITH DEPARTMENTS IN HOSTELS
AND WAS ACTUALLY CLUED IN THE IN
THE IN THE BUDGET FOR THE NRA
GUNNERY BUDGET RIGHT SO. SO
THERE IS NOT SERVE A LONG
STANDING ISSUE IN THE SALARIES
AND WE JUST GOT IT RESOLVED WE
ACTUALLY WANT CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THAT DOCUMENT AND SORT OF
IMPROVE THE TRANSFERRING THAT
ARGUMENT WE.
CHANGE THE BUDGET STRUCTURE OF
DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS TO IS
FOR TO PROVIDE.
A BETTER DISPLAY TO SEE CAN
SORT OF UNDERSTAND BETTER WHAT
EACH HOSPITALS KIND OF EXPENSES
WERE.
AND THEN WE'VE ALSO.
THE ESTIMATE BINDER IS NOW A
LOT BETTER PROJECT THAN IT WAS.
IN TERMS OF JUST LATE A LAY
PERSON BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT STATE HOSPITALS DOZEN SORT
OF WHAT SOME OF THAT JARGON THAT
THEY'VE COMMONLY USED ACTUALLY
MEANS I THINK IT'S THAT MORE
ACCESSIBLE DOCUMENT.
SO.
.
YOU KNOW THE FUTURE OF
LITERATURE LOW HANGING FRUIT
THINGS FOR US BUT THEY'RE REALLY
I THINK HELPED A LOT IN TERMS
OF.
HAVING A YOU KNOW THE LA O. IN
AND YOU AND AND YOUR CONSULTANTS
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF
SORT OF WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THE
TERM THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
STATE HOSPITAL.
SO.
I'M HOPING THERE WILL BE
ADDITIONAL THINGS IN THE SPRING
BUT I CAN'T SAY.
YOU KNOW I CAN'T I'D YOU KNOW
WORST THEIR SOLO WORK IN
PROGRESS AND WE HAVEN'T LANDED
ON ANY OF THEM YET SO. IN TERMS
OF THIS BUDGET CYCLE I'M
HOPEFUL.
BUT.
AND WE HAVE A PLAN THAT GETS.
SO MOVING FORWARD IS HOW CAN HOW
HOW DO YOU SEE YOUR WORK PRODUCT
FITTING INTO. OUR RESPONSIBILITY
OF BUDGET OVERSIGHT DO YOU SEE
THEM THE BEING YEAR YOUR WORK
PRODUCT GETTING INCORPORATED
INTO THE ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS IN THE MAY REVISE. OR
DO YOU SEE YOURSELF CONTINUING
TO GIVE THESE KIND OF UPDATES TO
OUR BUDGET OVERSIGHT OR IS THERE
COME A TIME AT WHICH. ARE WE
SHIFT TO THE OTHER BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEES AND YOUR WORK PRODUCT
GETS INCORPORATED AS THEY
CONSIDER DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
BUDGET WHAT WHAT HE CENTER
PROBABLY BOTH RELEASED A PARTLY
BOTH AYE I THINK THERE'S
DEFINITELY BE GOING TO BE BUDGET
PROPOSALS THAT THAT COME OUT OF
THESE IT. IS SHIFTING RESOURCES
CHANGE IN FUNDING STRUCTURE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND NOT
WILL YOU KNOW WE CAN TALK ABOUT
THAT HERE BUT I WILL DEFINITELY
MOVE THROUGH THE REGULAR.
SUBCOMMITTEE BUDGET PROCESS AND
THERE CAN BE OTHER THINGS THAT
WE SORT OF FINE AND WE WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU THAT MAYBE DON'T
HAVE A BUDGET ACCESS THAN THAT
WE'RE GONNA WANT TO TALK TO YOU
AND SAY THIS IS WHAT WE FOUND
THIS IS INTERESTING AND. AND IT
IS WHAT WE THINK.
SO IT'S IT'S KIND OF BOTH.
RIGHT THAT'S ENCOURAGING THANK
YOU YEAH.
THE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS.
A I WAS AN* BUT THE STATE
HOSPITAL YEAH I KNOW THAT THAT'S
BEEN.
THERE'S THERE'S BEEN AUDITS
DEBATE ONGOING ISSUES.
DOCTOR WEBER STRUGGLING ARM AYE
HOW HOW WAS YOUR WORK HELPFUL
AND SORT OF.
LOOKING AT THOSE ISSUES SALE AND
WAS IT OR WAS IT HELPFUL TO KNOW
THIS IS YEAH YOUR KIND OF
BUILDING A BUDGET FROM SCRATCH
AND MONITOR LOOKING AT PURELY.
YOUR PERFORMANCE ISSUES BUT
THAT'S BEEN SORT OF AN ON GOING
YEAH I MEAN ONE OF THINGS I
WANNA SAY ABOUT SAVE HOSPITALS
AND I'M IN SORT OF SHARING WITH
OUR FOLKS AT FINANCED HIS THAT
THEY. REALLY ACTUALLY COME A
LONG WAY AND THEY'VE DONE A LOT
OF WORK SINCE THEY WERE KIND OF
CARVED OUT A DEPARTMENT MENTAL
HEALTH AND THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
THINGS THAT THEY HAVE. ON DON
ARE READY TO SORT OF IMPROVE
OPERATIONS AND.
IT'S SORT OF IMPROVE THE.
CONSISTENCY OF OPERATIONS
PROSTATE HUSTLERS DEAFENING A
LOT MORE WORK TO BE DONE ON
THOSE SAME HOSPITALS KIND OF
HAVE BEEN DOING THIS KIND OF
THINGS ON THEIR OWN FOR AWHILE
YOU KNOW AND THERE'S A THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK YET TO BE DONE IN
TERMS OF SORT OF.
HAVING IT BE MORE CONSISTENT
ACROSS THE STATE POSSIBLE THAT'S
ONE OF THINGS ARE REALLY WORKING
ON THEM WITH.
ON AND A LOT OF IT IS THEY'VE
REALLY DONE A LOT OF WORK SO A
LOT OF WHAT WE'RE DOING IS IS
GETTING UP TO SPEED ON STUFF
THEY'VE ALREADY DONE AND STUFF
THAT THEY'RE ALREADY SORT OF
HOPING TO ACHIEVE.
AND THAT'S BEEN REALLY
ENCOURAGING AND IT'S AND IT'S
PROVIDED FOR VARIOUS WITH
COLLABORATIVE ON AND GREAT
RELATIONSHIP IN TERMS OF.
MAKING PROGRESS NOT REVEAL WHAT
AND IN THE MID TO ASK AS WE WE
KNOW THE MENTAL HEALTH IS.
I HUGE ISSUE WHETHER HOLES
AROUND THE CORRECTIONS ISSUE
AROUND THE HOMELESSNESS ISSUE
IT'S. AND IT'S AN ISSUE THAT.
ARM THERE AREN'T WAS OBVIOUS THE
ANSWERS RIGHT AND THEY'RE BEEN
CHALLENGES IN THE PAST IN THIS
THIS IS AN AGENCY THAT HAS
PRESENTED SOME OF THOSE SO.
ARM.
GOOD IT'S GREAT TO HEAR THAT
THERE COULD BE IMPROVEMENT SO
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO GO LOOK AT
PLAN B. BUT COULD JUST SUPPORT.
PLAN A PROM AND SO AS THAT
INFORMATION COME TO THINK IT
WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL TO.
BEGIN WITH GIVING IT TO THE
COMMITTEE GIVING IT TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEES ARMS THAT WE CAN
SORT OF DRILLING BECAUSE. I'M WE
WITH HER THE LAUNDRY LIST OF
COMPLAINTS RIGHT BUT THERE
HASN'T BEEN AN OBVIOUS PLACE TO
GO WITH RIGHT DON'T WE BECAUSE
THERE'S NO OTHER PLACE TO
NECESSARILY GO. RIGHT AHEAD
MONEY TO OPEN UP NEW HOSPITALS
ARE NEW SYSTEM SO ON BUT IT BUT
IT'S A HUGE A HUGE ISSUE AND AND
MAJOR AREAS THAT ARE OFF. PUBLIC
CONCERN RIGHT AND SO ON I MEAN
I'VE IT'S GOOD IT'S ACTUALLY
VERY REASSURING.
TO HEAR ABOUT THE PROGRESS AND
I'M GLAD THAT THEY'VE BEEN
COOPERATING SO THAT IT MAKES. ON
ME WANT TO CONTINUE TO WALK DOWN
THIS PATH THEY CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK BECAUSE. THAT THE HOPE IS
OBVIOUSLY IF WE CAN.
YOU TO THAT THE PROF AT THE
PROCESS FOR LEARNING. RIGHT NOT
OTHER AGENCIES YOU KNOW IT MAY
BE CHORUS SIMILAR STRAITS COULD
BUT ALSO LOOK AT IT IN IRAQ LA
DOT ORG BUT OUR HOPE IS NOT. A
AGAIN WHEN WE ALL MET PROBABLY
ABOUT A YEAR YEAR AND A HALF
AGO.
THAT THE PROCESS WAS NEVER
DESIGNED AS PUNITIVE IS REALLY
TRYING TO ON FIGURE HOW TO
ENHANCE PERFORMANCE RIGHT
WITHOUT HOW HARD WE GET OPTIMAL.
PERFORMANCE AROUND IT AND AND
REALLY HOW DO WE HAVE ON IN A
PUSHED AND NOT JUST IDENTIFY THE
PROBLEMS THAT REALLY GRAYSON AND
AND FIND SOLUTIONS SIERRA WHO I
KNOW THAT THE PROBLEMS ARE GOING
TO TAKE TIME. RIGHT ON THE FTA
FIXES CRITIC TOM IS NOT
SOMETHING THE WAVE A MAGIC WAND
AND A STOP.
I'M.
SO THEY JUST JOHN JUMPING TO
THAT TO THE NEW PROJECT DEPICT
PURCHASE TOXIC ADMINISTRATION
OBVIOUSLY YEAH I APPRECIATE THE
HELP ARM.
WITH THAT THE SOURCE OLD SLASH
NEW AGENCY ON WHICH JUST
WONDERING IF THERE'S ANY KIND OF
OBSERVATIONS ARE HIGHLIGHTS OF
HOW THINGS HAVE BEEN GOING FOR
THE FIRST
TAKE A SIX MONTH YEAH SO I CAN
HAPPILY CAN GIVE YOU A HIGH
LEVEL I WAS IN THE LEAD ON THAT.
ONE SO BUT I CAN KIND OF GIVE
YOU SOME OF THE INSIGHTS WE'VE
HAD ON THAT ONE. I'M SORT OF
THAT THE STRUCTURE THAT WAS
INHERITED FROM VIA WE MAY NOT BE
OPTIMAL.
AND SORT OF SORT OF HOW TO
THEIR DIVIDING THEIR DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES ON SO IT LOOKS
LIKE THEY'RE MEAN MAY NEED TO BE
SOME REDISTRIBUTION THEIR OF
SORT OF SOME OTHER TASKS AND
DUTIES AND WORKLOAD.
.
AND THEN.
ALSO THERE'S I THINK.
HOW THEY SORT OF IN FORCE ON
COMPLIANCE ACTIVITIES IN THE
FIELD OFFICES NEEDS TO BE BETTER
UNDERSTOOD WERE SO IT SEEMS SORT
OF SOME SOME CONCERN THERE MAY
BE SOME DISPARITIES AMONG FIELD
OFFICES IS ANOTHER? SORT OF
PLACE WERE SORT OF.
HOPING TO TAKE A DEEPER DIVE.
IN THAT PARTICULAR SHE WOULD
LOVE TO HAVE YOUR GUIDANCE
BECAUSE STARTING.
THERE WERE QUESTIONS I THINK WAS
OF THREE YEARS AGO MAYBE TWO
YEARS AGO WHICH ARE LOOKING AT
THE. FROM PROLIFERATION OF FIELD
OFFICES. DIDN'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND FUNNY ROLE THEY SERVE
RIGHT HOME MUCH OF THE MATERIAL
WAS UNLIKE PEOPLE WOULD WALK IN
WITH MATERIAL OR QUESTIONS
WRITTEN.
SO WE WE WOULD WE COULDN'T QUITE
FIGURE OUT WHY.
THE AGENCY WAS OPENING UP MORE
AND MORE RIGHT. OUT FIELD
OFFICES AND AND REALLY WHAT THE
EMPLOYEES IN THOSE OFFICES WYLER
WERE DOING. RIGHT SO THAT THAT
WAS DEATHLY A POINT OF.
HOME.
NOT AS A POINT OF CONCERN SO
WITH INITIATE YOU OWN TAKING A.
TAPPER LOOK AT THAT PURPOSELY.
GREAT.
OTHER QUESTIONS.
NO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE UPDATE THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
THE ARMED.
BUDGET FUNDING ON HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS REALLY THINKER.
DIRECTOR MET CAO FOR COMING
TODAY.
AS WELL AS LA OVER AND POUND
FINANCE.
IT AND DONE.
REALLY THIS ARE DID DID THIS
HEARING CAME ABOUT.
BECAUSE WE HAD ARE A QUESTION OF
FACT VERY INNOCENT QUESTION BY
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES.
ASKING.
HOW MUCH MONEY WE'RE SPENDING
ON HOMELESSNESS AND?
IT TOOK US FOUR WEEKS TO SORT OF
FIGURE IT OUT AND I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE'VE COMPLETELY FIGURED
OUT. THAT YOU HAVE MADE ME MORE
NERVOUS.
BUT WE REALLY WANTED TO SORT OF
HEAR FROM FROM THE AGENCY AND
ALSO HEAR FROM PART OF FINANCE.
SERVED YOUR VIEWPOINTS ON ON
WHERE STATE EXPENDITURES ARE
GOING IN TERMS OF.
A HOMELESSNESS OBVIOUSLY DID
WANT TO GET AN UPDATE ON THE.
WHERE WE ARE WITH THAT NO PLACE
LIKE HOME ISSUE I KNOW THAT
THERE IS I'M A LAWSUIT GOING ON
A JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHEN
WHEN OR IF THERE MAY BE ANY KIND
OF RESOLUTION COMING DOWN THE
PIKE? ON THAT AND OBVIOUSLY
THERE THERE'S BEEN ARM MAJOR
CALLS BY A NUMBER OF MEMBERS
NUMBER CITIES I'M I'M WORKING
WITH. A NUMBER OF MAYORS ASKING
FOR A ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR AUGMENTATION AROUND
HOMELESSNESS. SO.
IT IT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IF WE ARE GOING TO DO ANY KIND
OF PUBLICATION ONE UNDERSTAND
WHERE WHERE OUR MONEY IS TODAY.
HOW IT'S BEING SPENT AND ARM
WHERE SHOULD PIECE?
WHERE ANY NEW MONEY SHOULD BE
SPENT ARE MOVING DOWN THE ROAD
SO? A WITH ACTOR VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE OF BERTRAM ACCOUNT
FOR FOR YOU BEING HERE AND.
FLOOR SOURCE.
THANK YOU SUCH ENTERTAINING AND
AND MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE FOR
INVITING ME HERE TO TALK ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS.
IT'S AN ISSUE THAT I PACKER
DEEPLY ABOUT AND IT'S BEEN A LOT
OF TIME WITH MY STAFF AT EACH
CD.
WORKING ON BUT LET ME JUST.
START BY OFFERING WILL THE
CONTEXT ON ON WHERE THINGS ARE
ON HOMELESSNESS FRONT.
IN THEM AND GET SOME OF THE
BUDGET DETAILS.
BUT.
YEAH OBVIOUSLY MANY OF YOU
PASSED BY FOLKS.
ON THE STREET.
YOU SEE.
TEMPORARY SHELTERS ARE.
HOMELESSNESS AS A TERM AT ACTION
COMPASS IS MUCH MORE THAN JUST
FOLKS WHO LIVE ON THE STREET
INCLUDES FOLKS WHO MAY BE LIVING
IN SUBSTANDARD CONDITIONS. INTO
TEMPORARILY HOUSE IN SHELTERS
AND OTHER OTHERWISE.
EVERY YEAR. A THE FEDERAL
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT RELEASES ITS ANNUAL
ASSESSMENT REPORT TO CONGRESS.
AND THIS REPORT INCLUDES A POINT
TIME ASSESSMENT THAT TRIES.
TO ARTICULATE THE FULL SCOPE
AND BREADTH OF THE HOME OF THIS
CRISIS DOUBTS THE METROPOLITAN
LEVEL. BUT WITHIN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
CALIFORNIA'S COUNT WHICH I
ACCEPT THIS BETTER THAN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. I WAS ESPECIALLY
TROUBLING FOR TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THEM.
OF.
PARTLY BECAUSE OF THE NUMBERS
AND PARTLY BECAUSE WHAT TOPPING
CALIFORNIA'S ACTUALLY DIFFERENT
THAT WHAT WE'RE SEEING BY AND
LARGE IN THE REST THE COUNTRY.
WHERE AS MUCH THE COUNTRY IS
ACTUALLY MAKING MEANINGFUL
PROGRESS ON LAURIE HOLMES
COUNTS?
I CALIFORNIA'S POINT TIME COUNTS
ARE GOING UP AND OTHER GOING UP
SIGNIFICANTLY SIXTEEN PERCENT
STATEWIDE TERMS THE TOTAL
NUMBER.
OF HOMELESSNESS.
WHERE THE HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS HOMELESS
ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT IN THE STATE?
AND.
WHILE THIS IS A STATE WIDE
PHENOMENON JUST ABOUT EVERY AREA
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE THIS
UPTICK.
WE DO SEE SOME AREAS THAT HAVE
BEEN PARTICULARLY IMPACTED OUR
ALAMEDA COUNTY WENT UP BY. A
THIRTY NINE PERCENT YEAR OVER
YEAR LA COUNTY WENT UP BY TWENTY
THREE PERCENT YEAR OVER YEAR.
AND SO IT BEGS THE QUESTION OF
WHAT'S GOING ON HOW DO WE GET
HERE.
AND I I I WOULD BE REMISS NOT TO
SORT OF START BY SAYING YOU KNOW
THERE IS A COURT CHALLENGE HERE
WHICH WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT I'VE
TALKED ABOUT WITH THIS COMMITTEE
AND IN THE PAST WHICH IS. A
CALIFORNIA IS SYSTEMATICALLY
CHRONICALLY UNDER BUILDING HOMES
AND HAS BEENFOR A PERIOD OF
MULTIPLE DECADES.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY TRUE AND
THE MULTI FAMILY AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AREA.
ARE WE'VE AVERAGED STATEWIDE
ONLY ABOUT EIGHTY THOUSAND NEW
HOMES PER YEAR OVER THE LAST
COUPLE DECADES.
BUT LESS THAN HALF OF WHAT BY
THE STATE HAD PROJECTED WE KNEW
WE NEEDED TO BE BE BUILDING TO
KEEP PACE.
AND.
.
IN THE LOWER INCOME PORTION.
OUR DATA THAT WE RECEIVED FROM
CITIES AND COUNTIES EVERY YEAR
THROUGH OUR ANNUAL PROGRESS
REPORTS THIS PARTICULAR
TROUBLING.
IN THIS CURRENT REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ALLOCATION CYCLE
BUT WE HAVE ONLY PRODUCED SEVEN
PERCENT.
OF WHAT WE KNEW WE NEEDED IN THE
LOWER INCOME AREA. AND TODAY A
NINETY SEVEN PERCENT OF TRIPS
DICKENS ALL BUT A HANDFUL.
ARE BEHIND PIECE IN TERMS OF
DELIVERING ON THAT LOWER INCOME
SEGMENT.
MORE TROUBLING AS WELL AS THAT
THE A WHERE WE ARE SEEING THAT
HOUSING GETTING PRODUCED.
IS NOT.
CONSISTENTLY IT IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY OF FARTHER
AWAY FROM JOBS IT IS FARTHER
AWAY FROM AMENITIES IT IS
FARTHER AWAY FROM TRANSIT. AND
SO WE ARE PUTTING A FURTHER
BURDEN.
WHEN WE ARE BUILDING HOMES AND
FOLKS TALKED BY THOSE HOUSES
BECAUSE OF A CONTINUED
DEPENDENCE ON CARS AND LONG
COMMUTES.
A DIFFICULT ACCESS THE RESOURCES
AMENITIES IN JOBS THEY NEED TO
BE STABLE AND THE STATE HOUSE.
BOB THAT FACTOR HAS.
IS MUCH THE REASON WHY THE
UNITED CENSUS BUREAU LAST YEAR
PLACE CALIFORNIA NUMBER ONE IN
THE NATION. ARE FOR ITS POVERTY
RATES ONCE COST OF LIVING IS
FACTORED IN.
AND THAT IS MUCH OF THE REASON
WHY.
TODAY CALIFORNIA ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION HOUSEHOLDS ON
INDIVIDUALS HOUSEHOLDS.
ARE CAN BE ARE I HAVE WORST
CASE HOUSING NEEDS WHICH IS A
HUD TERM THAT CAPTURES LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS NOT CURRENTLY
RECEIVING ANY KIND OF RENTAL
ASSISTANCE OR SUPPORT. BETTER
PAYING EVERY MONTH MORE THAN
HALF OF THEIR INCOME.
IN HOUSING COSTS THIS A
DEMOGRAPHIC IS ONE THAT WE NEED
TO BE WHAT WORRYING AND WATCHING
VERY CAREFULLY.
THERE'S GOOD RESEARCH OUT THERE
THAT SHOWS THAT THIS IS THE.
BOB THIS THIS OF A BODY OF
HOUSEHOLDS ARE ONES WHO ARE
FALLING BEHIND ON TURN IT ON
HEALTH CARE NOT SAVING FOR THE
KIDS' EDUCATION. UP AND HEART
USES THIS NUMBER AS A PROXY FOR.
FOR HOMELESSNESS.
I'M HERE CALIFORNIA THAT NUMBER
IS UP BY ALMOST A THIRD FROM
WHERE WE WERE A DECADE AGO.
NOW PART OF THE STORY IS ALSO
CLEARLY. ABOUT THE LACK OF
SUBSIDY THAT HAS BEEN GOING OUT
TO SUPPORT THIS POPULATION DIXIE
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
END UP IN A SIGNIFICANT PART OF
THAT STORY.
DOES ALSO THAT TIE INTO THE
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE HAVE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
NOT OVER THE LAST DECADE WE HAVE
SEEN FEDERAL CUTS TO OUR QUIRK.
A AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROGRAMS
COMING INTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO THE TUNE OF ABOUT
THIRTY FOUR PERCENT.
THOSE CUTS HAVE BEEN COMPOUNDED
IMPACTED OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS.
AS MANY MAY BE AWARE OF THE
FEDERAL THAT REFORM FEATURE ONE
THAT A CHANGE THE TAX CODE LAST
DECEMBER.
HAS HAD THE CONSEQUENCE OF
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING THE VALUE
OF THE FEDERAL LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT.
COR PART OF BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
BUT SUCH THAT FROM TAX REFORM WE
ARE NOW GONNA BE SEEING AN
ESTIMATED. OF FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF LAST PER YEAR
IN INVESTMENT. ARE GOING INTO
AFFORDABLE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ANNUAL.
SO THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT.
YOU KNOW IT'S ALL WE DO KNOW
WHAT WORKS I THINK THERE IS A
VERY STRONG BODY OF LITERATURE
PRACTICE AROUND HOMELESSNESS.
THAT GIVES US SOME SHOULD GIVE
US SOME COURAGE AND HOPE.
WE'VE ACTUALLY SEEN A NUMBER OF
STATES SMALLER STATES ADMITTEDLY
I'M AND CITIES AROUND THE
COUNTRY WHO HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
ABLE TO HAVE THE MAYORS
GOVERNORS GET OUT THERE DECLARE
THAT THEY HAVE ATTAINED. WHAT'S
CALLED FUNCTIONAL ZERO EITHER
WITH A VETERAN HOMELESSNESS OR
CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS.
IN FACT RIVERSIDE COUNTY WAS
ABLE TO HIT THAT MARKER.
NOT THAT LONG AGO FOR FOR.
A CHRONIC VETERANS HOMELESS SO
WE WE REDUCE THE PLACES THAT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PUT THIS ALL
TOGETHER. AND THAT THE USE OF
CIGARETTES THE BUTTE INGREDIENTS
TEND TO BE. NO CLEARLY NUMBER
ONE TACKLING THIS WORST CASE
HOUSING YOU POPULATION WE CANNOT
SOLVE HOMELESSNESS IF WE CAN'T
SOLVE THE LARGER ISSUE.
AROUND.
A RENT BURDEN FOR LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS.
BUT SECONDLY A INVESTING IN WHAT
THE LITERATURE SHOWS ACTUALLY
WORKS FOR THOSE WHO EXPERIENCE A
PRICKLY EPISODIC AND CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS A CONTINUUM OF
CARE.
WITH COORDINATED ENGAGEMENT BY
THE FULL SPECTRUM OF PUBLIC
AGENCIES THAT TOUCH ON
HOMELESSNESS ISSUES.
ABOUT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
UTILIZING BY NAME A DIRECTORIES
THAT USE THE HOMELESS MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION SYSTEMS TECH TO
TRACK.
INDIVIDUAL BY INDIVIDUAL.
BUILDING OUT COORDINATED ENTRY
SYSTEMS AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL
THAT LINE UP.
THE INDIVIDUALS MOST IN NEED A
MOST VULNERABLE.
WITH HOME SAYS WITH THE WITH
THE HOUSING OF THE RESOURCES
THAT BECOME AVAILABLE SO WE HAVE
GOOD MATCHING.
NOT RAPID RE HOUSING AND OTHER
INVESTMENTS TO QUICKLY MOVE
FOLKS WHO ARE ABOUT TO HIT
HOMELESSNESS OR OF JUST TO HELP
US IS QUICKLY BACK OFF THE
STREETS.
AND OF COURSE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WHICH IS
REALLY THE GOLD STANDARD HERE IN
TERMS OF THE LONG TERM SALUTE
BUILDING HOUSING. THAT PROVIDES
AFFORDABILITY AND INTEGRATED
SERVICES TO HELP FOLKS WHO ARE
DEALING WITH THE COMBINATION OF
MENTAL ILLNESS.
A PHYSICAL IT INJURY A SUBSTANCE
ADDICTION TO TACKLE.
I'M NOT LEAVE TALK BECAUSE OF
OUR PAST YOU'LL GO THROUGH THAT
THE FULL LIST THAT THAT UP
FINANCE FISK SO CABLE WE PUT
FORWARD IN TERMS THE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS ARE OUT THERE BLOODY
FLAG A FEW THINGS THAT WE'RE
DOING AT THE STATE LEVEL THAT I
THINK ARE WORTH.
MATCHING THEM FIRST ON THE
COORDINATION PIECE
HAVE TO BE A BIG PIECE OF OUR
SOLUTIONS.
I AM VERY PLEASED REPORT.
THAT THE STATE'S HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL. WHICH WAS CREATED. OF
S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY.
IN THE PREVIOUS SESSION.
HAS NOW BEEN FULLY CONSTITUTED
WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD OUR SECOND
MEETING OF REPRESENTATIVES OF
ALL THE KEY STATE AGENCIES
DEPARTMENTS THAT TOUCH INTO
HOMELESSNESS INCLUDING
REPRESENTATIVES FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ADVOCATES.
AND THAT BODY HAS BEGUN THIS FOR
IMPORTANT WORK BOTH OF MAKING
SURE THAT WERE PROMULGATING
HOUSING FOR STANDARDS ACROSS ALL
OF THE HOMELESSNESS RELATED
PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE
MINISTERS. ABOUT CATALOGING AND
INVENTORYING OTHER PROGRAMS ARE
WORKING.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
BEGINNING TO PRIORITIZE AREAS
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR INTER
AGENCY STATEWIDE.
ENGAGEMENT ON HOUSING.
ON HOUSING ACTIVITIES.
.
BUT THE DRUM HOUSING NEEDED
ELEMENT.
ALSO HAS BEEN. PUTTING OUT A
NUMBER OF FUNDING FOR NUMBER TO
PROGRAMS THAT ARE THAT ARE WE
THINK ARE KEY TOOK LONG TERM
SOLUTIONS.
WELL AS MUCH A COUPLE ONE IS ARE
THE MERSEY SOLUTIONS GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH IS A ACTUALLY NEW
PROGRAM THAT WAS LAUNCHED WITH
INFUSION OF STATE. FUNDING OF
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. THAT
LEVERAGES FEDERAL FUNDS THE
FEDERAL EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS
GRANT PROGRAM.
BACK SHE DELIVERS FUNDING TO
EVERY CONTINUUM OF CARE EVERY
LOCAL REGION IN THE STATE.
ARE TO HELP THEM ACTUALLY WITH
PRIORITIZING APPROACHES FROM.
DOT AND COORDINATED ENTRY OF
RAPID RE HOUSING EFFORTS. A
BUILDING OUT THEIR OWN CAPACITY.
WHEN OUR SECOND ROUND OF OF THAT
PROGRAM RIGHT NOW WE'RE ACTUALLY
PUTTING OUT THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS OF STATE.
E. SG RESOURCES GAP PROGRAM
FUNDING IN APRIL.
BOB WE'RE ALSO IN OUR FOURTH
ROUND NOW A FUNDING THROUGH OUR
VETERANS HOUSING AND HOMELESS
PREVENTION WHICH IS A VERY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM.
PUTTING OUT ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR FOR BUILDING PERMITS PART
OF HOUSING TO SERVE OUR OUR
VETERANS.
.
CHAIRMAN YOU MENTION THE NO
PLACE LIKE HOME PROGRAM I'LL
JUST NOTE THAT THAT IS
UNDERGOING A COURT VALIDATION
PROCESS OF BEFORE WE CAN PROCEED
WITH THAT. UP I CAN REPORT OUT
THAT A HEARING DATE.
FROM OF THE FROM THE ROLE THE
LOWER COURT HAS NOW BEEN SET. UP
FOR A JULY THE TWENTY THIRD.
TO HAVE A TALK.
MORE ABOUT THAT.
A WE ALSO OR ARE PLEASED TO NOTE
THAT WE WILL BE RELEASING A AND
ANTICIPATED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OPPONENTS PART OF
HOUSING THROUGH A MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING PROGRAM. A LATER THIS
YEAR THESE ARE ACTUALLY FUNDS OF
COME BACK TO US A THROUGH A
NUMBER OF LEGACY PROGRAMS WERE
PLEASE TO PUT OUT.
TOUGH FIFTH FIFTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS.
PERMITS PORT PERMITS WERE
HOUSING ABOUT.
M. AND AGAIN I HAVE TO EMPHASIZE
THE HOUSING PIECE OF IT IS JUST
ONE COMPONENT.
WE ARE ALSO CLEARLY SUPPORTED
AND ALL THIS WORK BY THE GREAT
WORK GOING ON BY OUR COLLEAGUES
AT PLACES LIKE THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES THEIR WHOLE
PERSON CARE PILOT USING. FEDERAL
MEDICAID WAIVERS TO DELIVER. A
USED FEDERAL FUNDS ARE CREATIVE
WAYS THAT LEVERAGE HOUSING
RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
HAS BEEN IN PLEDGING NOW TWENTY
FIVE DIFFERENT COUNTIES.
RUN THE STATE. OTHERS GREAT WORK
OBVIOUSLY HAPPEN IN TERMS OF
SERVICES REPRESENTED HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO COULD. LIKELY SPEAK
TO THE TOWERS HOUSING PROGRAM
THAT HELPS.
ARE VERY VULNERABLE HOMELESS
FAMILIES.
THAT ARE TEETERING ON THE EDGE
OF HOMELESSNESS TO PREVENT A
FICTION OR TO GET RE HOUSE
PROMPTLY.
I LOOK FORWARD OBVIOUSLY UP WITH
HOUSING PACKAGE THAT WAS PASSED
A LATE LAST YEAR. WE HAVE SENATE
BILL TWO WHICH PROVIDES A
PERMANENT. A FUNDING SOURCE FOR
HOUSING AND PRIORITIZES HALF OF
THE FEES COLLECTED IN THE FIRST
YEAR. OR AN ESTIMATED HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
PURPOSES OF HOMELESSNESS.
NOT MY STAFF HAS BEEN.
ENGAGING ALREADY WITH A
STAKEHOLDERS BEGINNING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT ARE SOME OF THE BEST
WAYS THAT WE CAN USE THESE
FUNDS.
YOU PROBABLY OFFICIALS
OFFICIALLY FILL SOME OF THE GAPS
THAT ARE OUT THERE DEPLOY
THROUGH SOME OF THESE SUCCESSFUL
CHANNELS THAT HAVE ALREADY
NOTED.
HOW WE DO ANTICIPATE A ROBUST
PUBLIC PROCESS ALSO TO DO THE
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS OF
IDENTIFYING HOW TO PRIORITIZE
THESE FUNDING?
THOSE COLLECTIONS ARE OBVIOUS
SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION.
AND THE REVENUES WE WILL.
BE AVAILABLE TO US WE GET A
SPATE OF THE SOONEST US THIS
FALL TO DO IT DURING THIS ROUND
OF FUNDING THERE. WOULD LIKELY A
FUTURE ROUND OF FUNDING. WITH
FUNDS COLLECTED LATER HALF OF
THE YEAR. COMING IN TWENTY
NINETEEN.
AND THAT SENATE BILL THREE OF
COURSE.
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR NUMBER
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
AND IF ENACTED BY THE VOTERS A
ONE OF THE PRIMARY PROGRAMS
THERE'S ARE MULTI FAMILY HOUSING
PROGRAM WHICH.
WE WOULD EXPECT WOULD INCLUDE
EIGHT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
COMPONENT THAT WOULD HELP US
BUILD MORE OF THE PROMISE FOR
PASSING THAT SO DESPERATELY
NEEDED.
SO.
WITHOUT I'LL JUST CONCLUDE BY
SAYING THAT I HAD THE HONOR NOT
LONG AGO ABOUT GOING OUT AND
SPEAKING AT A.
GRAND OPENING FOR UP A PROPERTY
IN A ORANGE COUNTY CALL POWDERS
LANE. THAT WAS SERVING
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS VETS.
AND A REALLY BEAUTIFUL COMPLEX
ACTUALLY USED.
RECYCLED A STEEL SHIPPING
CONTAINERS TO A VERY ELEGANT
ARCHITECTURE ACTUALLY HOUSE
FOLKS AND ACTUALLY BUILD THIS
OUT BURGER RICK QUICKLY.
AND I WAS INSPIRED BY THE SORT
INNOVATION BUILDING MATERIALS ON
THE CREATIVITY THAT WE'RE SEEING
AMONG FOLKS RECEIVING OUR
FUNDING. ENCOURAGED BY HOW
QUICKLY THIS PROJECT WAS ABLE TO
ACTUALLY GO FROM FUNDING
ACTUALLY GETTING A PROPERLY
STUFF I HAD A LONG CHAT WITH.
ONE OF THE RESIDENTS.
OMIT MANY JAMES WOOD SPENT LAST
FEW YEARS LITTLE WHICH LIVING IN
HIS CAR I'M UP A BY THE RIVER.
DOG FIFTY.
AND AND YOU KNOW HE CONVEYED TO
ME HAS EXCITEMENT FINALLY
FINDING A HOME IN A PLACE TO BE
STABLE WAS EVER INFECTIOUS AMBER
MOTIVATING BEFORE FOR ME SO.
I'LL CLOSE BY JUST SAYING LOOK
THESE ARE THE TOUGHEST
CHALLENGES THAT I THINK ANY OF
US TAKE ON IS TRY TO MAKE
PROGRESS IN HOMES AREA. UP BUT I
DO THINK.
WITH CONTINUED NO POLITICAL
WILL WITH A STRONG AND REGION'S
COORDINATION OF ALLUDED TO.
AND WITH SOME PATIENTS I THINK
WE CAN CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY
THAT WERE.
DO OR FROM THE LYMPHOMA COME.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR TO
KIND OF BUILD OFF OF DOCUMENT
CASTS.
COMMENTS TO JUST GIVE YOU SOME
CONSIDERATIONS IN THINKING
ABOUT.
BOTH ALMOST FUNDING IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET AND POTENTIAL
AUGMENTATIONS FOR DIS ON THE
SERVICES GOING FORWARD.
HI I WANTED START BY
HIGHLIGHTING ONE PIECE OF THE
WAS MENTIONED BY DIRECTOR MET
CAPTAIN THAT IS THE. THE HALF OF
THE FIRST YEAR FUNDING FROM S.
B. TWO BY THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ESTIMATES ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE. MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET.
SP TWO DIRECTED OF THAT PART OF
FUNDING TO GO TO.
PROVIDE SERVICES TO HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS GENERALLY OTHER WAS
IN A LOT OF SPECIFIC DIRECTION
IN S. B. TWO AND WE UNDERSTAND
THE ADMINISTRATION IS IS. A
PLANS AND IS CURRENTLY
UNDERTAKING A A STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS TO DETERMINE THE BEST
USE OF THOSE FUNDS ABOUT OF
COURSE WOULD SUGGEST.
THAT YOU ALL A CONSIDER WHAT
PRIORITIES YOU MIGHT HAVE FOR
THOSE FUNDS.
AND CONSIDER GIVING MORE
SPECIFIC DIRECTION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION ON HOW YOU MIGHT
LIKE TO SEE THOSE FUNDS SPENT
WHETHER IT BE FOR A ADDITIONAL
CONSTRUCTION SUBSIDIES OR
SERVICES.
TO ATTACH TO PERMIT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING OR FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
ALMOST INDIVIDUALS OTHER A LOT
OF A CHOICE IS THERE A FOR THIS
PART OF MONEY.
THAT YOU MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
GIVING ADDITIONAL DIRECTION TO
THE ADMINISTRATION.
.
AGAIN ANOTHER SET OF
CONSIDERATIONS.
THAT THE COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE WANT TO CONSIDER
WITH.
WITH ANY ADDITIONAL OF HOMES
FUNDING ARE.
A WHAT CHALLENGES AND BARRIERS
MAY BE IN PLACE TO A GETTING
THIS FUNDING OUT THE DOOR A TO
LOCAL ENTITIES AND THEN.
ULTIMATELY A CONSTRUCTING THE
HOUSING IN AND BRING IT ON LINE.
ONE UNDERLYING CONSIDERATION IS
THE FACT THAT THAT ONLY A SUBSET
OF BUILDERS AND NON PROFITS
I DO A SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN
BILLS PERMITS SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
AND STATE FUNDING IN PAST YEARS.
HAS BEEN SOMEWHAT SPORADIC
IT'S RELIED ON A ONE TIME
ALLOCATIONS IN BOND FUNDS IN
BECAUSE OF THIS.
THE YOU KNOW THERE HASN'T BEEN
QUITE INCENTIVE FOR A ROBUST.
INSTITUTION OF NONPROFITS AND
BUILDERS A SPECIALIZING IN THIS
TYPE OF DEVELOPMENT.
TO KIND OF TAKE HOLD IN THE
STATE.
AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE MANY
OF THESE NONPROFITS ARE STARTING
TO STAFF UP NOW AND AND RAMP UP
IN RESPONSE TO SOME OF THE
RECENT ALLEGATIONS IN THIS AREA.
BUT SOME OF THAT WILL WILL TAKE
TIME.
AND SO THAT IS THAT IS ONE
THING TO CONSIDER IS YOUR
THINKING ABOUT.
HOW QUICKLY THE CURRENT FUNDING
IS MOVING OUT AND HOW QUICKLY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING MAKE IT UP?
A ANOTHER THING TO CONSIDER IS
THAT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING DOES
REQUIRE A MORE SIGNIFICANT US
SUBSIDIES ON A PER UNIT BASIS
THAN A TYPICAL AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DOES. ON THIS IS THIS IS
A GENERALLY DO THE THE SIMPLE
FACT THAT A HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
TYPICALLY CAN PAY A LITTLE
LITTLE OR NOTHING IN RENTS EVEN
COMPARED TO. THE GENERAL LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THAT IS IN A GENERAL AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
AND LOOKING AT A LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CUT TRADED PROJECT
DATA FROM THE LAST FEW YEARS.
SHOWS OF THAT THAT THE TYPICAL
STATE SUBSIDY NEEDED FOR A
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
UNIT. WAS ABOUT TWICE THAT OF.
JUST GENERAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
AND.
THIS NEED FOR GREATER SUBSIDY
CAN MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
THESE KINDS OF PROJECTS TO
PENCIL OUT IN THAT CAN CONSTRAIN
THE NUMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES
THERE ARE FOR. A DEVELOPERS TO
BRING THESE KIND OF PROJECTS
FORWARD AS COMPARED TO A JUST A
TYPICAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
CITING A.
THE SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
A CONTINUES A TO BE SOMEWHAT OF
A CHALLENGE AND IT AND IT DOES
TAKE TIME.
WE.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS.
MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS IN THE
THIS AREA WITH A LEGISLATION
LAST FOR YEARS TO ATTEMPT A TO
STREAMLINE THESE LOCAL
PROPHECIES AND REDUCE THE AMOUNT
OF TIME IT TAKES TO THESE
PROJECTS TO MOVE FORWARD.
BUT THE BUT THERE'D STILL
REMAIN SOME REALITIES THAT THAT
CREATE BARRIERS.
AND CREATE TIME AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL ONE KEY FACTOR IS A LANE
LAND AVAILABILITY.
OF MUCH OF THE HOMELESS PROBLEM
IS CONCENTRATED OUR IN OUR
DENSELY POPULATED URBAN AREAS
WHERE OF VACANT AND UNDER
UTILIZED LAND IS
VERY SCARCE.
AND DEVELOPERS OF SPERM PERMITS
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING ARE COMPETING
WITH OTHER KINDS OF HOUSING
DEVELOPERS WITH COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPERS WITH ALL ALL A HOST
OF OTHER KINDS OF A POTENTIAL
USES FOR THAT SCARE SLOWING AND.
AND THAT CAN CONSTRAIN THE
NUMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES
AVAILABLE FOR PROJECTS TO COME
FORWARD IN A GIVEN YEAR.
I'M POUNDED A BY A LOCAL ZONING
RULES.
THAT.
CAN. ARE NOT ALWAYS NECESSARILY
ALIGNED WITH.
.
WITH THE ECONOMIC REALITIES OF
DEVELOPERS.
WE FOUND FOR EXAMPLE THAT TWO
THIRDS OF MULTI FAMILY
DEVELOPMENTS AND LARGE CITIES
AND LA IN THE BAY AREA.
NEEDED ZONING CHANGES TO MOVE
FORWARD IN RECENT YEARS.
AND AGAIN WE THE LEGISLATURE
HAS.
.
BEFORE HIS A PASS SOME
LEGISLATION TRYING TO ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM.
AND I THINK IT'S MADE SOME SOME
BIG STEPS THERE OF BUT THIS IS
LIKELY TO CONTINUE TO REMAIN A
SOMETHING OF AN ISSUE FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
ANOTHER CONSIDERATION.
THAT HASN'T BEEN AN ISSUE TODAY
BUT THAT COULD BECOME AN ISSUE
IN FUTURE YEARS. IS THE
AVAILABILITY OF.
TAX CREDITS THROUGH THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM AS DIRECTOR MET CALF
MENTION.
THE LONG COMMITTING TAX CREDIT
IS KIND OF THE FOUNDATION OF
ALMOST ALL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS.
A AND THIS THIS PROGRAM.
HAS.
TWO PARTS THERE'S THE THE NINE
PERCENT CREDIT WHICH PROVIDES
DAY.
MORE SUBSTANTIAL SUBSIDY FOR
AFFORDABLE DEVELOPMENT THERE'S
THE FOUR PERCENT CREDIT.
WHICH PROVIDE THE LESSER
SUBSIDY BUT IS A PAIRED WITH TAX
EXEMPT FINANCING THAT'S PROVIDED
THROUGH THE STATE TREASURER'S
OFFICE.
AND BOTH SIDES OF OF THIS
PROGRAM BOTH THE NINE PERCENT
CREDIT. AND DETECTIVE GOT
FINANCING OUR OUR.
CAPT ANNUALLY BASED ON LIMITS A
SET BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
A RIGHT NOW THE NINEPERCENT
CREDIT IS A IT IS COMPETITIVE
IT'S OVER SUBSCRIBED.
BUT ON THE FOUR PERCENT SIDE.
THERE'S BEEN ENOUGH OF FUNDING
TO GO AROUND FOR ALL THE
PROJECTS THAT HAVE COME FORWARD
IN RECENT.
BUT OTHER THERE IS THE
POTENTIAL.
IN THE COMING YEARS.
THAT.
IF NO PLACE LIKE HOME IN S. B.
THREE DO COME ONLINE ASSUME. AND
YOU COUPLE THAT WITH THE S. B.
TO FUNDING IN SOME OF THE LOCAL
BOND MEASURES THAT HAVE PASSED.
THAT ALL OF THAT FUNDING COMING
ONLINE AT ONCE.
IT'S LIKELY OR POSSIBLE OR
LIKELY THAT EVEN THE FOUR
PERCENT SIDE OF THE LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDIT PROGRAM COULD
BECOME OVER SUBSCRIBED.
THAT WOULDN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
THAT YOU COULDN'T HAVE ALL THE
PROJECTS MOVING FORWARD. OF BUT
IT COULD MEAN YOU HAVE TO SPREAD
OUT THOSE TAX CREDITS.
MORE THINLY ACROSS A LARGER
NUMBER OF PROJECTS WHICH WOULD
THEN REQUIRE AS ESSENTIALLY A
STATE TO FILL IN THE ADDITIONAL
SUBSIDY NEEDED FOR THOSE
PROJECTS MAKING. THE KIND OF THE
STATE'S COST FOR EACH UNIT. A
MORE EXPENSIVE.
THINK ABOUT WITH THAT THAT'S THE
KIND OF A SUMMARY OF SOME OF THE
HIGH LEVEL CONSIDERATIONS THAT
THAT THE COMMITTEE MIGHT WANT TO
TAKEN.
TO ACCOUNT AND THINKING ABOUT
HOMELESS FUNDING MOVING FORWARD
AND HAVE IT ANSWERED QUESTIONS.
GREAT THANK YOU.
GOING BACK TO YOUR EARLIER POINT
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES OF GETTING
FUNDS OUT THE DOOR. DID YOU ARM
FIND ANY PROGRAMS IN PARTICULAR
THAT WERE MORE EFFECTIVE AT
MOVING.
MONEY FASTER NOW A DIRECT
QUESTION ABOUT ALEJO AND
DIRECTOR MATT CASH
A OBVIOUSLY WE DON'T WANT TO BE
PENNY WISE AND POUND FOOLISH
BUT.
I WE DO HAVE A CRISIS AND WE DO
NEED TO GET SHELTER UP AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE.
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT.
.
BUT I THINK IN TERMS OF MOVING
MONEY OUT MORE QUICKLY ONE OF
THE KEY CONSIDERATIONS.
IS.
TRYING TO LEVERAGE.
EXISTING PROGRAMS IN EXISTING
REGULATIONS.
THAT.
WHETHER IT BE THROUGH EACH CITY
OR THROUGH.
THE THE STATE LONG COME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM.
THAT.
ARE ALREADY IN PLACE TO NOT
REQUIRE. EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS EASIER OR A REGULATORY
PROCESSES
FOR EACH CD TO START MOVING A
THE FUNDING OUT THE DOOR.
TRADITIONALLY.
ANY CD OF THAT KIND OF WORK
COURSE PROGRAM HAS BEEN THE
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM.
AND THERE ARE.
YOU KNOW POTENTIALS TO KIND OF
HAVE SET ASIDE FOR THE TIME
PROGRAM TO FOCUS ON PARTICULAR
POPULATIONS LIKE A SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
AND AND MAYBE THE DIRECTOR
MIGHT HAVE.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
BUT NO I THINK I THINK IF YOU
YOU KNOW THAT I THINK FOR FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE A BUILDING ON
WHAT WORKS INTERVIEW THE PROGRAM
SO BACK IN THE PAST IS
CONSISTENTLY THE BEST WAY THAT
WE CAN MOVE. DEFINING OUT THAT
SAID WE ARE COMMITTED TO
IMPROVING AND VACATION WHENEVER
WE DO ANOTHER ROUND OF FUNDING
WE DO A. DO SOME FINE TUNING
SOME UPDATING AND WE WANTED TO
DO THAT WITH THE S. B. THREE OF
PROGRAMS AS WELL. HIT THE OTHER
THING I JUST MENTION. IT IS
ANOTHER SOMETIMES A TEMPTATION
TO SAY.
YOU KNOW WELL WE SHOULD PUT ALL
THIS MONEY OUT.
INTO.
.
YOU KNOW BUT SHOT SHELTERING
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE WE
CAN WE CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN MUCH
MORE QUICKLY. UP AND I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW OF SHELTER
NAVIGATION CENTERS HAVE AN
IMPORTANT.
PLACE IN THE SORT OF CONTINUUM
OF OF CARE. ABOUT BUT I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT NOTE THAT THAT WE
DON'T SEE.
LONG TERM POSITIVE OUTCOMES FOR
SHELTER INTERVENTIONS IN TERMS
OF ACTUALLY MOVING FOLKS. IN
ISOLATION OUT OF HOMELESSNESS
AND INTO STABILITY BUT RAPID RE
HOUSING IS OF A VERY PROMINENT
PART OF OUR TOOL KIT ITS IMAGE
WE WE WE SUPPORT A THERMOS
WASN'T SCRAP PROGRAM. THAT WE
BELIEVE IT'S A MUCH MORE COST
EFFECTIVE AND TO HUMANE OPTION
BUT COMPARED TO THE SHELTER
SYSTEM. I'M AND YET SORT OF THE
THE DEFINITIVE HUD STUDY ALL ON
THIS MATTER DID NOT FIND THE
RAPIDLY HOUSING ACTUALLY HAD
BETTER OUTCOMES THAT THE CHILD
SHOULD SIMPLY MORE COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO DISSOLVE
PROBLEM. THE YET LOOK LIKE OF
THE US SOLUTION THAT REALLY IS
WHAT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON FOR THE
CHRONICLE MOST HAS TO BE PERMITS
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING ON THE
SOLUTION THAT WE HAVE TO FOCUS
ON FOR THIS LARGER WORST CASE
HOUSING IS POPULATION. HAS TO BE
GETTING MORE SUPPLY HIGH BOTH
MARQUERITE AFFORDABLE THERE'S NO
WAY AROUND IT THAT THAT'S GONNA
TAKE TIME.
THIS BLOOM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
AND YOU'RE AT AND FOR YOUR FOCUS
ON THIS. VERY IMPORTANT
TROUBLING LONG TERM TROUBLING
TROUBLING ISSUE.
I I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU
MISTER METCALF THAT TO A OF.
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
VERSES SHELTER CARE THAT IS THE
GOLD STANDARD IT'S WHAT WE
SHOULD BE MOVING AT TOWARDS BUT
THE REALITY ON THE STREETS.
AND NOT EUPHEMISTICALLY ON
STREETS ACTUALLY ON THE STREETS.
IS THAT WE'RE SEEING INCREASING
NUMBERS OF INDIVIDUALS.
A CAMPING OUT ON THE STREETS.
INTO IN.
AND IN MOBILE HOMES
A AND AND AND THE LIKE AND
THAT'S ALL OVER THE STATE AND
IT'S AND MORE CITIES THAN IT'S
EVER BEEN AND AND IT'S SET IN
PLAIN VIEW IT'S OUT OF SIGHT IN
REVENGE AND.
AND SO.
AS ONE WHO'S BEEN WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE FOR TWENTY YEARS. AND
WHO VERY STRONGLY BELIEVES IN
THE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
A MODEL.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT THAT.
NOT PLACING SOME FUNDS INTO
SHELTER CARE. ITEM AND EXPECTING
WITH THE WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT WE'RE GONNA SEE INCREASING
NUMBERS OF INDIVIDUALS ON THE
STREETS AS.
PROBABLY NOT REALISTICALLY AND I
WISH THAT I WAS WRONG IN THAT.
A AND ANNA AND OBSERVATION.
BUT.
.
AT I DO THINK THAT RAPIDLY
HOUSING AS IS IMPORTANT TO A
RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND EVICTION
PER.
PREVENTION ARE ALL AREAS THAT
ARE RECEIVING.
A TWO LITTLE FUNDING AT THIS
POINT IN TIME GIVEN THE.
A ABYSMAL STATE OF OUR HOUSING
EFFORTS.
IN SPITE OF EVERYTHING WE'VE
DONE IN THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
TO REFORM A HOUSING LAWS.
I I I I.
IT THINK THAT KEEPING
INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR CURRENT
HOUSING IS OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE AND NOT GETTING
ENOUGH ATTENTION CURRENTLY SEWER
I WONDERING IF YOU COULD PROVIDE
SET THE BOTTOM DOLLARS. ON THOSE
THREE AREAS SO THAT I KNOW HOW
MUCH WE'RE ACTUALLY SPENDING NOW
AND AND THEN YOU MAY NOT HAVE
THE INFORMATION WITH YOU NOW
BUT.
A IT WOULD BE GOOD TO KNOW. OWE
A WHAT THE OUTCOMES ARE WHAT
WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY SEEING IN
TERMS OF. OF.
FOR WHATEVER DOLLARS WERE
SPENDING FOR EXAMPLE ON RENTAL
ASSISTANCE HOW MANY PEOPLE WERE
ABLE TO KEEP.
IN THEIR HOMES AS OPPOSED TO
THEM LOSING A HOUSE WHERE
THEY'VE HAD A RENT INCREASE OR
ARE. A A A A PAYCHECK OR RENTAL
PAYMENT AWAY FROM. OF BEING ON
THE STREETS
IS THAT POSSIBLE.
WELL I I GUESS I WOULD SAY THAT
YOU KNOW I MISS NEVER SEE
SOLUTIONS GRANT PROGRAM WHERE
WERE WE PUT UP ABOUT FORTY.
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS YEAR THERE
I MISSION CAO WORKS A HOUSING
STABILIZATION PROGRAM MISS BUT
FROM SOCIAL SERVICES AND SLICK
AT THE CHART HERE. AND THAT'S
YOU KNOW EIGHTY UP THIS SUMMER
FIVE MILLION. DUMPED THAT ALL OF
THOSE DOLLARS ARE GOING TO
RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
THE BULK OF THEM ARE GOING TO
SOME SORT OF AN INTERVENTION
THAT YOU'RE HOPING TO BECOME.
STAND THEIR EXISTING HOME OR IF
THEY FALLING OUT CAN QUICKLY
MOVING THEM BACK AND IN IN THE
HOUSE SIX OF THOSE ARE SHORT
TERM STOPGAP. KINDS OF SOLUTIONS
I'M.
I GUESS I SHOULD TAKE THE THAT
THE BULK OF THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE THAT IS GETTING THE
PLOY IN CALIFORNIA IS COMING
FROM THE FEDERAL SIDE THESE ARE.
THE ON HOUSING CHOICE VOUCHERS.
.
WE WE WE HAVE HAD SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THINK AGAIN FEDERAL CUTS
UP GETTING INTO THAT WE'VE
WRITTEN HERNIA CARRYING A LOT
PUBLIC HOUSING AUTHORITIES FOR
HOLDING BACK ON LETTING YOU
VOUCHERS BECAUSE THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR. THE RESERVE RESERVE
BALANCES WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT WE ARE
NOT GONNA GET SIGNALS FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION THEY'RE PROPOSING
TO.
TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT CUTS THEIR.
PUMP ANY OTHER PLACE I WOULD
MENTION I SHOULD MENTION THIS IS
INSTANTLY AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
WE'VE HAD SOME VERY INNOVATIVE
EXCITING PRICES LA COUNTY. OF SM
CISCO ABOUT TO TRY TO USE.
TOUGH FLEXIBLE LOAN POOL FUNDS
THAT ACTUALLY ARE DEPLOYED WITH
A HEALTH CARE VESTMENTS TO PLACE
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS INTO
EXISTING HOUSING BY PROVIDING
THEM WITH LOCAL RENTAL SPORTS
PAIRED WITH SERVICES.
UP THE WHOLE PERSON CHARACTER
POLITICS ALSO BEEN VERY FACILITY
ABOUT THAT ABOUT CLEANER THAT WE
CAN WE CAN DO MORE TO SUPPORT
BUNDY'S CUT BEST PRACTICE LOCAL
LEVEL.
WHAT WOULD BE GOOD TO HAVE AN
ASSESSMENT?
OF OF FOLLOW ALL OF THOSE
PROGRAMS.
VERSES THE NEED THAT'S OUT
THERE IN THE INCREASING NEED.
HI I I CERTAINLY THINK WE ARE
NOT A POSITION WHERE WE CAN
EXPECT.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING OR HELP FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND.
SO EVEN AT THE LEVELS I
UNDERSTAND WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
THERE MIGHT BE A PULL BACK THAT
WOULD BE TRAGIC OF BUT. A EVEN
IF THERE'S NO PULL BACK WE NEED
MORE DOLLARS NOT FEWER. THERE'RE
IS SET MY UNDERSTANDING AND. ONE
OF THE DYNAMICS HERE NOT MY
UNDERSTANDING ONE OF THE
DYNAMICS HERE IS. THAT.
I'LL BE
BECAUSE OF THE STATE OF THE
RENTAL MARKET SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHERS ARE. TIED OF DIFFICULTY
UTILIZED AND MANY OF THE MORE
EXPENSIVE AREAS OF THE STATE AND
CLUED IN AREAS SET IN AND AROUND
MY DISTRICT WHERE. THERE HAS
BEEN A TRADITION OF A GOOD DEAL
OF SECTION EIGHT HOUSING THERE
ARE SOME FIFTEEN HUNDRED
VOUCHERS I IF I UNDERSTAND THE
NUMBER. CORRECTLY IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS THREATENING TO
REMOVE BECAUSE THEY WERE IN HIS
LAST YEAR BECAUSE THEY SIMPLY
COULDN'T FIND. A AND A A LAMB
WHO WAS WILLING TO TAKE THE
VOUCHER BECAUSE THE VOUCHER
AMOUNT IS LOWER THAN THE MARKET
WILL PAY TO THAT LANDLORDS
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THAN THE
MARKET WILL PAY. SO THERE'S A
DISCONNECT THERE AND THE.
OUTRAGEOUS CONSEQUENCE OF THAT
IS THAT WE ARE SEEING VOUCHERS
GO UNUSED. AND A GOVERNMENT THAT
IS SAYING WELL YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE NOT USING THEM WHICH
SKINNER PULLED BACK THE THE
VOUCHERS AND YOU'LL NEVER SEE
THEM AGAIN.
I AM NOT A NOT A POSITIVE
OUTCOME AYE I THINK BECAUSE.
I'VE AND I'M REPEATING MYSELF
BUT IN TERMS OF THINGS I'VE BEEN
SAYING OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
BUT THE. COST OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS.
OF SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
FIX.
I HAD TO FOLKS IN MY OFFICE
TODAY WHO A WERE REFERENCING CA
OUR CHAIRS DISTRICT.
WHERE A A PREVIEW IT COST FOR
HOUSING IS UPWARDS OF EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
CURRENTLY AND WHILE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COSTS MIGHT BE?
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN THAT WE
NEED IT IT'S STILL IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD MANY PLACES OF FOUR
HUNDRED FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS UNIT AND YOU REVEREND
STUFF SHIPPING CONTAINERS WHICH
IS NOT MY FAVORITE TO. A
DIRECTION TO COPE BUT WE NEED TO
FIND WAYS A INNOVATIVE WAYS OF
LOWERING THE PER UNIT COST. NO
MATTER HOW MANY DOLLARS WE HAVE
AND THERE ARE CONSIDERABLE NEW
RESOURCES UP THROUGH A A SPS TO
AND.
VARIOUS OTHER OF PROGRAMS THAT
ARE BEING INJECTED INTO THE
SYSTEM.
I. THE LOWER THE PER UNIT COST
IS THE MORE YOU. SIMPLE FACT IS
THE MORE UNITS WE CAN BUILD WITH
THAT MONEY.
I'M AND THE NEED IS SO GREAT
THAT OF THE ALL OF THE BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT. WE HAVE THAT
ARE COMMITTED IN WILL BE
COMMITTED TO BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WILL BE INSUFFICIENT IN
ANY EVENT
SO WE GET MORE.
BANG FOR OUR BUCK BY A A BY
LOWERING THE PER UNIT COST AND I
THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT A IS
URGENT THAT WE NEED TO. AT AT
ATTEND TO.
I A AS WELL.
AND THIS TIES INTO THE ISSUE
ABOUT A A ABOUT SHELTER CARE THE
TIMELINES FOR BUILDING HOUSING
IN GENERAL IN THE MARKET PLACE.
AND IN THE OF THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING REALM ARE SO LENGTHY.
THAT THE A AND THE COSTS ARE SO
HIGH THAT THE IDEA THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO. AGENDA UP
THE HOUSING MACHINE IN OF
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION MACHINE. UP
IN TIME TO A ADDRESS THE
HOMELESSNESS OF THOSE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY ON THE STREET OR IN
DANGER OF FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS IN THE NEAR TERM.
OF IS SIMPLY UNREALISTIC AND SO
AGAIN A IT IS SIR OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE THAT WE PAY MORE
ATTENTION TO PROVIDING. A OF OF
SOME SHELTER SOME CARE FOR THOSE
WHO WERE ON THE STREET SOME
ADDITIONAL RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND
OF ACTION PREVENTION FOR THOSE
WHO ARE. I'D A NEAR TO
HOMELESSNESS.
THANK YOU I'M.
I I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA MONICA OBVIOUSLY.
WOULD BOTH
HUGE SUPPORTERS OF SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING I I AGREE WITH YOU
DIRECTOR THAT THAT WOULD BE. THE
IDEAL SITUATION TO GO HA BEEN
KNOWING WE HAVE I THINK YOU SAID
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND. PEOPLE
ON THE STREETS TODAY. ON.
WHAT I MEAN WHAT'S?
WHAT WOULD BE ARM AN OPTIMISTIC
TIMELINE RIGHT NOT NOT?
NOT EVEN A REALISTIC ONE BUT
NOT OPTIMISTIC ONE.
ARE OF HOW MANY YEARS WOULD IT
TAKE TO.
YOU KNOW AS AS WERE WERE
DEATHLY.
INCREASING HOUSING SUPPLY
TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU THERE
WHEN WE NEED TO INCREASE JUST
MARQUERITE HOUSES SUPPLY. ARM.
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING SUPPLY IN
THEN.
POTENTIALLY EVEN SHELTERS I
GUESS I GUESS HOW MANY HOW MANY
YEARS WILL IT TAKE.
IF IF WE LOOKED AT IT TODAY AND
SAID HEY. UM TO MAKE IT TO MAKE
A DENT IN THIS THING DON'T TAKE.
FIFTY PERCENT EIGHTY PERCENT OF
THE US. POPULATION.
HOW MANY YEARS I THINK IT?
I.
.
I I HESITATE TO TO TRY TO GIVE
YOU A NUMBER THERE ARE JUST SO
MANY UNKNOWNS THERE. YOU KNOW I
MENTIONED EARLIER IN MY REMARKS
THAT YOU KNOW WE WE SHOULD TAKE
SOME COMFORT THAT THERE ARE
OTHER STATES AND CITIES AROUND
THE COUNTRY. THAT TOOK ON A YOU
KNOW WITH EX MADE EXPRESS GOALS
TRYING GET THE FUNCTIONAL ZERO.
A LOT ABOUT HAPPEN TO TWENTY TEN
TWENTY TWELVE LOT OF THE MOVIE
BEEN ABLE TO GET TO ZERO. NEARBY
TWENTY SIX INCH WAS OF T.
COMMUTE TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
BUT THE REALITY IS THOSE PLACES
ARE NOT CALIFORNIA NO THEY ARE
NOT FACING THIS INCREDIBLE SORT
OF ECONOMIC CHALLENGE OF OF OF
STAGNANT INCOMES COMPOUNDING
WITH. BALLOONING HOUSING COSTS
AND SO. NOTE ARE ACRE CHALLENGES
WE ARE GOING TOWARD UPSTREAM
HERE RIGHT WE TRY TO MAKE
PROGRESS BUT THE TIDE IS GONE
GOING AGAINST US IN MANY WAYS IN
TERMS OF JUST THE GROWTH OF
THIS.
WHAT I CALLED WORST CASE HOUSING
IS POPULATION?
WHAT THE GUY AT THE CHALLENGES
IN WEALTHIEST TO WHAT TURNED THE
ECONOMY OFF THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD NOT A NUMBER HOW THAT
WOULD BE THE WAY TO LOWER THE
HOUSING COSTS? ON OF THE WHICH
IS PRETTY YOUR UPS RIGHT MEMBERS
WERE STRUGGLING WITH.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW.
HOW TO DO THIS YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT'S?
YOU KNOW HOW CAN YOU TAUGHT DO
UP WE CAN WRITE THAT THAT I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE EXAMPLES
OF YOUR PRODUCT. A THINKING OF
ON. YEAH I DID I DID ONE ASKED
PARTNER FINDS YOU IN GOOD
MENTION DIRECTOR COUPLE NUMBERS.
AROUND.
IMAGE P. IN THE FIFTY MILLION
IN THE U. S. G. THIRTY SIX
MILLION. NOT AND NEITHER OF
THOSE SHOW UP ON MY.
CHARGE WHICH I BELIEVE ARE THE
CHARTS THAT MY STAFF AND.
FINANCE WORKED ON IS THERE A
REASON WHY.
MAY AND ECONOMIC DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE CHART THAT YOU HAVE
BEFORE YOU REPRESENTS THE
FUNDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AND SO FROM
IN THE CASE OF IOUS SHE FOR
EXAMPLE FUNDING THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY APPROPRIATED WAS NOT
INCLUDED AGAIN TO AVOID DOUBLE
COUNTING.
I'VE A SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN CHART.
WHICH WHICH WAS ACTUALLY
APPROPRIATED IN THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN BUDGET ACT.
.
AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BCP
PROVIDED THE RESOURCES TO
DISTRIBUTE THOSE FUNDS.
OKAY. SO THE MONEY WE
APPROPRIATED.
I IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WOULD BE
IN THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET.
I'M THE THE FUNDING WOULD HAVE
RATED YOU AND THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
BUDGET ACT.
FOR THAT SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
BUDGET CONGRESSIONALLY SO'S WE
SHOULD LOOK AT THE SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN BUDGET AS WELL.
THAT WERE SET ON THE FUNDING WAS
PROVIDED FOR THAT THIRTY FIVE
MILLION YESTERDAY THAT'S THAT
WOULD BE REFLECTED THERE.
SO IT'S LIKE AS PART PART OF OUR
OUR OUR CHALLENGES AND LIKE I
CAN'T DIRECTED EVERYBODY WHICH
IS.
ON.
IS ARE YOU KNOW WE WERE WERE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO TACKLE THIS PROBLEM
MONITOR? WE KNOW THAT MONEY
ISN'T THE ONLY WAY TO DO IT.
THAT.
WE CAN'T EVEN SEEM TO QUITE FIT
ROUTE.
WHERE THE MONEY'S GOING WHAT ITS
BEING SPENT ON? AND HOW MUCH
MONEY.
THERE IS.
SO IS THERE A WAY AT LEAST THAT
CAN BE.
ADDRESSED VERY.
QUICKLY.
ANYBODY CAN ANSWER.
I GUESS I WOULD JUST ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS THAT YOU EXPRESSED
THAT IT IS.
ANY CHALLENGE TO QUANTIFY
BECAUSE WE'VE TAKEN ALL OF THE
ABOVE STRATEGY AND WE COME AT IT
FROM A DIFFERENT APPROACHES AND
SO. ON. THE STATE FIRST
ATTEMPTED TO IDENTIFY ALL THE
FUNDING ACROSS VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS.
WITHIN THE LAST HANDFUL OF
YEARS AND SO YOU'RE RIGHT THAT
IT IS A CHALLENGE IN CONTINUING
TO WORK AT THIS.
BUT I ALSO WOULD LIKE NOTABLY WE
WE WE HAVE BEEN ADDRESS WE CAN
GOING THROUGH THE SOFA CUSHIONS
LOOKING FOR THE NICHOLS THAT
THAT WE CAN HEAR HIM BUT BECAUSE
OF THE. YOU KNOW THE URGENCY OF
THE SITUATION SO SO MANY CASES
WHAT THE NUMBERS THAT WERE
TALKING TO HERE REFLECT FUNDS
WERE WE'VE GONE BACK TO PASS
YOUR ALLOCATIONS AND ACTUALLY
CLAWED BACK DOLLARS BECAUSE OF
NON PERFORMANCE. OF EXTRA LIKE
THOSE MONIES ARE MORE
EFFECTIVELY IN THERE. SOME CASES
WE HAD DOLLARS OUT WITH THE
LEGACY PROGRAMS THAT ARE NO
LONGER RELEVANT AND TRY TO
REPURPOSE THEM THROUGH THE SPORT
OF HOUSING. MUCH DIRECTORY AS
WELL SO IT'S A COMBINATION OF
THINGS WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN THE
ABSENCE OF YOU AT THIS POINT
TIME NOT HAVING. YOU KNOW THE
DEDICATED PERMITS SOURCE TO DRAW
ON OR GET NOT HAVING BEEN ABOUT
A NEW A NEW INFUSION BOND FUNDS.
OKAY ARE I HEAR THAT.
.
NOT REALLY THE MOST ACCEPTABLE
ANSWER IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
ARMS.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO SEE HAPPEN?
ON.
BUT POSSESS WHICH IS THIS THIS
HAS BEEN CLEARLY. COMMUNICATED
TO BE. THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE NOT
JUST IN MY CITY BUT I THINK IN
MOST.
MOST CITIES ACROSS THE LEAST THE
LARGE CITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
HARM.
WE ARE ALL GETTING GAS
WHAT THE STATE IS DOING. HOME
THE STATE IS IS TRYING TO DO
MORE IN THIS AREA BUT ITS HARD
TO DO MORE IF WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE HAVE DONE.
SO HARM.
HOW SOON CAN WE? GET A CLEARER
PICTURE OR A MORE ACCURATE.
PICTURE I UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT OF. GOING
BACK LOOKING AT OTHER PROGRAMS
GETTING MONEY RE PURPOSING I
THINK THAT'S FABULOUS I THINK
IT'S.
CHAU INGENUITY BUT. HOME
IT DOESN'T HELP US THROUGH OUR
PROCESS.
AND I DON'T WANNA BE
BUREAUCRATIC ABOUT A PLAY DO I
LEAST WANT TO KNOW HOW MUCH
MONEY WE'RE SPENDING AND WHERE
IT'S GOING.
SOUTH CENTRAL HAVE THAT.
IN A MOCHA FIGHTER.
AFTERNOON SIR DANIEL PRINTED
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND WE CAN
WORK WITH STAFF TO COME UP WITH
THAT INFORMATION DEVELOP A
TIMELINE KILLED IT MORE SPECIFIC
PSALM ON EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR.
HAD MENTIONED.
AT THIS IS A UNIQUE CHALLENGE.
BUT DAMN I'M. I'M CONFIDENT WE
CAN DO IT I WOULD SAY. HOPEFULLY
WITHIN A WEEK OR TWO DELEGATE
RICH YET BECAUSE BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THIS. THESE TOOK FOUR
WEEKS IN THE FACT THAT THIS IS
NOT.
YOU KNOW IT AN ENTIRE.
COMPLETELY YOU KNOW.
STOCK PLEASE STOP SHOT I THINK
IS CONCERNING.
RIGHT AND I THINK THAT ON.
I OBVIOUSLY I DON'T WANT TO
ADVOCATE FOR PROP MORE
PREPARATIONS IF THERE IS
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR. IF THE
MONEY THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
SPENDING HASN'T REALLY PROVEN TO
BE EFFECTIVE EITHER.
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THAT JUST
MORE MUCH JUST MORE MONEY IS
ALWAYS DANCERS WAS WE OBVIOUSLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
AS WERE DEPLOYING FUNDS THAT
THERE'S A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
PROTECTIVENESS TO IT MISTER
BLUE.
I.
THERE ARE NUMBER OF FIFA OF
FOLKS AROUND THE STATE WHO HAVE
SUGGESTED THAT WE. OF A ASK THE
GOVERNOR TO CREATE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY OR DECLARE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AROUND HOMELESSNESS
AND WHETHER OR NOT THAT IS. AN
APPROPRIATE ARE A GOOD IDEA
PUTTING PUTTING THAT ASIDE I
THINK WE SHOULD BE TREATING THIS
ISSUE AS IF IT WERE AN EMERGENCY
SO.
.
I I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK
ABOUT IT THAT WAY I AM NOT
SAYING THAT THAT YOU DON'T SEE
IT IS IMPORTANT AND THEY
HAVEN'T.
BEEN PUTTING EFFORT INTO IT BUT
I I THINK THAT IF WE START TO
FOCUS ON THE ISSUE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY. BEYOND. THAT WILL
BE HELPFUL I I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT THE OF THE PEOPLE OF THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES FFSA ARE
ENGAGED ON THIS ISSUE AS AS THEY
ARE AND AND.
MANY PLACES AROUND THE STATE
AND OF VOTER DAY OF.
A.
TO GET THE AMOUNT OF DATA.
THE SALES TAX MEASURE THAT IS
INTENDED TO.
AT AND THAT WILL GENERATE
FUNDING.
TO A BILL TEN THOUSAND UNITS
OVER TEN YEARS.
THAT'S THE GOAL OF.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
I'VE GOT THIS JUST AS WE SEE AT
THE STATE LEVEL AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THERE ARE BOTTLENECKS
IN OUR LOCAL EFFORTS AND THERE'S
CURRENTLY. NO PLAN FOR ACTUALLY
STE A. OF FIGURING OUT HOW WE
INCREASE THE HOUSING PRODUCTION
AFFORDABLE HOUSING A OF FOR
HOMELESS PRODUCTION FROM WHERE
IT IS NOW TO WHERE IT NEEDS TO
BE TO GET TO A THOUSAND. UNITS A
YEAR IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
UP TO THE WE GET TO THAT TEN
THOUSAND AND TEN YEARS.
SO WE ALL AND THAT THE REASON I
BRING THIS UP IS THAT WE ALL
FROM THE LOCAL LEVEL TO THE
STATE TO THE FEDERAL LEVEL NEED
TO BE. WORKING TOGETHER TO A
FOCUS ON EVERY PLACE WHERE
THERE'S A BOTTLE NECK AND AYE
AYE EVERY ISSUE THAT A OF WHICH
THERE ARE A MYRIAD HAD THAT
AFFECT HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS. AND
ARE AFFECTING OUR ABILITY TO
REALLY ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
EFFECTIVELY.
ESTO ONE QUICK FOLLOW UP
QUESTION SO I GUESS WE WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE THIRTY SIX
MILLION.
THAT.
.
WHEN TO ESG FROM THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN BUDGET BUT MY STAFF
JUST.
ON.
A BRIEF IN ME I I GUESS WE WE
BELIEVE THERE'S A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR APPROPRIATION FOR TWENTY
SIXTEEN AND.
I GUESS WHEN DID EITHER THE
FIFTY OR THE THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS GO. AND WHAT DID IT GO
TO.
WEAVER REFERRING TO A FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR APPROPRIATION FOR
ON. THAT EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS
GRANT PROGRAM BUT ACTUALLY TEN
MILLION OF THAT WAS SPECIFIED TO
BE USED BY THE.
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES AS
OF THAT MONEY WENT TO.
YES AND SO THERE'S THIRTY FIVE
MILLION APPROPRIATED IN THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN BUDGET ACT FOR
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
BUT RESEARCHERS WERE NOT
PROVIDED FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO
ADMINISTER THOSE FUNDS UNTIL AT
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BCP WAS
APPROVED AND SO NOW IN THE
CURRENT YEAR THE PROCESS AND. IS
UNDER WAY TO DISTRIBUTE THE
SPENT
GOT IT. AND INDEED A WITH.
OAS DID THE TEN MILLION THAT
WAS THE.
YES I AM.
UTV AND EMERGENCY SERVICES
PERMANENTLY CUT.
ERICA
OKAY.
ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL.
FOLLOWING.
YEAH AND WE WE APPRECIATE WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS ARM.
SOMETHING THAT YOU'VE.
ME OVER AND OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS ONLY BEEN RAMPING UP TO SO
IT'S IT'S NOT WE'RE NOT TRYING
TO BE IMPATIENT WE DO WANT TO.
MAKE SURE WERE. GETTING SOME
PROPER ACCOUNTS WE CAN REALLY
FIGURE OUT HOW BEST TO. AUGMENT
RESOURCES AND WHERE TO PUT THEM
THIS IS DEFINITELY AN AREA THAT
WE WILL BE NO YOU FEEL A SENSE
OF URGENCY I THINK WE FEEL A
SENSE OF URGENCY BUT WE ALL WANT
TO BE.
GROWN IN THE SAME DIRECTION. SO
I'M.
WELL YES SIR I WAS.
FORGET THE PART OF PUBLIC
COMMENT.
I ANY PUBLIC COMMENT
SORRY SORRY ABOUT THAT.
MY APOLOGIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN LUIS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YEAR THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE TODAY'S DISCUSSION
AROUND HOMELESSNESS AND WOULD
JUST ASK THAT WE CAN REALLY. PUT
THEM ATTENTION ON YOUTH AND
YOUNG ADULTS ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE A LOT OF
TIMES IN THE CONVERSATION THEY
DO GET MESSED WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT VETERANS ARE TALK ABOUT
CHRONIC.
BUT THE NUMBER FOR YOU IS
GROWING AND IT'S OVER FIFTEEN
THOUSAND LAST POINT TIME CANNOT
AND IT'S GROWN. THIRTY TWO
PERCENT LOSS TWO YEARS I THINK
IS THE TO STICK AROUND FIFTY
PERCENT OF THE CHRONICALLY HOMES
ADULTS EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS
THAN WHEN THEY WERE EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD. I KNOW
SOME A WOMAN RUBIO IS I'M
WORKING ON HAVING ADAM.
SINCE WINNING SET ASIDE FOR
HOMELESS YOU SPECIFICALLY AND
REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO
SOMETHING AND WHATEVER LARGER
CONTEXT SPECIFICALLY FOR YOU.
SO THANK YOU.
DEAR MISTER CHAIR I MEN'S OSCAR
VIEQUES I'M HERE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES ALSO KNOWN AS SHE SEC.
ON JUDGEMENT OBJECT TO MINUTES I
COULDN'T JUST A.
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS AS AS THE IMPORTANT
START EVEN UNDERSCORE HERE SO
I'VE BEEN SERVING ON THE ALL
KIND WERE SUPERVISORS ARE FOR
THE LAST FOUR YEARS AND PRIOR TO
THAT I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE AS A CITY COUNCIL MEMBER.
AYE FROM FOURTEEN YEARS IN THE
CITY OF WEST SACRAMENTO'S HAVE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY THE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO KIND OF LOOK THAT
CITY AND COUNTY LANDS AND
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
WORKING TOGETHER AND HOW
IMPORTANT THAT'S GOING TO BE.
ENTER THE TUNNEL ON THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS I ALSO SERVED ON
AND MANY MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SERVED ON AT HEART COMMITTEES TO
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS ISSUES OF.
OF HOMELESSNESS AS YOU KNOW.
DESPITE THE DECLINING NUMBERS OF
HOMELESS BETWEEN AT TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE LAST
THREE YEARS WE'VE SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE.
I AM IN RESPONSE TO THAT.
ARE THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES AND THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES ACTUALLY GOT TOGETHER TO
DISCUSS
HOW IT IS THAT WE MIGHT WORK
TOGETHER MORE EFFECTIVELY MORE
EFFICIENTLY. AND AS A RESULT OF
THAT IN TWENTY SIXTEEN A WE
DEVELOPED A JOINT TASK FORCE.
I OF THAT TASK FORCE WAS CO
CHAIRED BY MYSELF AS WELL AS
WELL AS HOW WITH THE CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER I JAN ARTICLE
FROM.
GRASS VALLEY.
AND I'M HAPPY TO REPORT THAT
ACTUALLY DESPITE HOW LONG IT
TAKES TO GET THESE KIND REPORTS
TOGETHER WE HAVE A WONDERFUL
PORTABLE GONNA RELEASE TOMORROW.
A THAT WILL PROVIDE A WHOLE
RANGE OF INFORMATION THAT MUCH
OF WHICH IS BEEN TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER TODAY. IN TERMS OF SOME
OF THE BEST PRACTICES EMERGENCY
PRACTICES EXAMPLES OF GOOD
PARTNERSHIPS WITH CITIES AND
COUNTIES ARE DOING. A BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES
AND GOVERNMENT WERE RISK AVERSE
WE DON'T NECESSARILY WANT TO
TAKE THAT RISK WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE GONNA BE SUCCESSFUL.
AND THESE THIS REPORT WILL SERVE
AS A GOOD EXAMPLE OF OF A PLACE
WHERE YOU CAN SEE WHAT CITIES
AND COUNTIES HAVE DONE WORKING
TOGETHER TO BE. A SUCCESSFUL.
AND SO WHILE THIS REPORT ISN'T
NECESSARILY GOING TO BE A SILVER
BULLET. ARM IT CONSERVATORY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO HELP THEM
IDENTIFY PROGRAMS INITIATIVES
PARTNERSHIPS.
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES AS EACH
COMMUNITY IS REALLY UNIQUE AND
HAS ITS OWN UNIQUE CHALLENGES.
AS I WANT THINK LEGISLATURE FOR
ITS ACCOMPLISHMENT OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST TWO YEARS
WITH THE PASSAGE OF SB TWO S. B.
THREE AT NO PLACE LIKE HOME.
ABOUT THE FACT REMAINS THAT IN
CALIFORNIA.
WERE HOME TO TWENTY ONE OF THE
THIRTIETH MOST EXPENSIVE RENTAL
MARKETS IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
AND OF THE STATE'S TWO POINT TWO
MILLION EXTREMELY LOW INCOME AND
VERY LOW INCOME. A RENTER
HOUSEHOLDS OTHER COMPETING FOR
ONLY SIX AND SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND
AFFORDABLE RENTAL UNITS WHIMS
CONTINUE TO PARTNER WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE STATE.
LOTS LITTLE LOT OF MOVING PIECES
RIGHT NOW WE KNOW THE GUIDELINES
ARE BEING DRAFTED FOR S. B. TWO
LAWYERS ARE WORKING ON A NO
PLACE LIKE HOME VOTERS WILL
CONSIDER WHETHER NOT THE STATE
SHOULD. ISSUE S. B. THREE A
BONDS IN NOVEMBER. BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT MONEY FROM THE STATE
COMING IN THE COMING YEAR COULD
BE PUT TO USE.
IMMEDIATELY BY BY CITIES AND
COUNTIES ON CONCLUSION IT'S
CLEAR THAT HOMELESS HAS REACHED
A CRISIS POINT FOR ALL OF US ARE
HOPING THAT THEY COULDN'T HIRE.
A COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
WILL TRULY PARTNER WITH
COUNTIES AS WE GO FORWARD TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER.
THANK YOU.
ANY THE PUBLIC COMMENT.
ONE LAST JUST POINT OF
CLARIFICATION YOU MENTION THE
COURT DATE IN JULY.
FOR NO PLACE LIKE HOME TO DO WE
HAVE ANY GAS AFTER THAT COURT
DATE HOW SOON WE MIGHT GET SOME
GUIDANCE OR RESOLUTION.
THEM OKAY SO WE COULD BE HERE
FOR WOULD BE COULD BE THERE FOR
A LOT OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT YOU BECOME TODAY